GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE- SENATORS STEVE GLAZER
CHAIR OF THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON STUDENT SUCCESS
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE IN THE ROOM OR-
VIEWING I SAW. ON YOUR
TELEVISION SET- THIS IS I THINK
OF THE SIX OR SEVEN TH HEARING
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
STUDENT SUCCESS- AND AS WE ALL
KNOW TE MEMORY FUNCTION OF OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM IS TO
EDUCATE OUR STUDENTS AND HELP
THEM OR AGREE. AND IT'S CLEAR
THAT ALL THE DATA THAT WE'VE
LOOKED AT THAT THE LONGER
STUDENTS STAYS IN SCHOO. YA
FOUR YEAR THE LESS LIKELY THEY
ARE TO LEAVE WITH A DEGREE AND
THIS OUTCOME CAN LEAVE THEM- IN
DEBT. UNABLE TO EARN A SALARY
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO CLIMB THE
ECONOMIC LADDER THAT TIES SO
VITAL TO THEM AND THEIR FAMILY
AND TO OUR STATE. THAT IS WHY
STUDENT SUCCESS IS SO IMPORTANT
AND THAT IS WHY WE NEED TO
FOCUS OUR RESOURCES ON HELPING
STUDENTS GRADUATE- IN A TIMELY
FASHION- AND WE'RE GONNA IT
HERE WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
TODAY. AND THEY INEVITABLE CAN
TO THIS CAUSE WITH THEIR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE-
INTRODUCED BY- CHANCELLOR WHITE
AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM THAT. I AUTHORED
TOGETHER WITH THE CENTER DALY
ALLEN- THE- SYSTEM HAS. AT HAS
DONE SOME REALLY AMAZING THINGS
AND I KNOW THE DOCTOR MINERS
GONNA TALK ABOUT THEM BUT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE-
OF THE ELEMENTS OF THAT. THAT
FOR YEARS AGO- THEIR GRADUATION
RATE- WAS 19% AND TODAY IT IS
TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT. 28% AND
THAT- AND THEY SET A GOAL TO
REACH 40% BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND I KNOW THAT- THAT THAT WORK
THAT HAS BEEN DONE WAS NOT
EASY. AND IT SHOWS A GREAT
COMMITMENT BY THE CHANCELLOR IN
THE SYSTEM LEADERSHIP FIVE OUR
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENTS- BY THE
FACULTY BY THE STAFF STUDENTS
AND MANY MORE IN THE
LEGISLATURE O JOIN TOGETHER TO
TRY TO. HELP THE SYSTEM I DO
THE WORK BETTER BETTER AT AND I
WANT TO JUST NOTE THAT DURING
THAT FIVE YEAR PERIOD- WHERE
THE IMPROVEMENT HAS HAPPENED-
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR I PROVIDED AT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. AND
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO HELP THE
SYSTEM MEET THESE NEW HIRE
GRADUATION ALL TARGETS GOOD
NIGHT AND MAYES LIKE A LOT OF
MONEY. I THAT SYSTEM AT THAT
TENDS OVER SO WILLIAM.
RESOURCES EVERY YEAR. SO IF YOU
LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT THE STATE PROVIDE OF THIS.
AND OF THAT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED THE LAST
FEW YEARS THAT'S ABOUT A 1%
LITTLE BIT LESS THAN A 1%
IMPROVEMENT IN RESOURCES TO GET
A 40% 47% INCREASE IN
PRODUCTION OKAY THINK ABOUT
THAT ANYWHERE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT YOU GAVE LESS THAN
ONE PERCENT- ENHANCE RESOURCES
AND GOT UP 47% RATE OF RETURN
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY HAVE
DONE THAT'S EXTRAORDINARY. AND
THAT IS BECAUSE THEY TARGETED
THOSE RESOURCES FOR ADVISING
FOR COUNSELING FOR ADDITIONAL
FACULTY- AND- IT'S MAKING A
HUGE DIFFERENCE AND I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE THE SYSTEM AND ALL
THOSE INVOLVED IN OVER HERE
FROM TO SUCCESS STORIES AT SAN
JOSE AND SACRAMENTO IN JUST A
FEW MINUTES. I THAT IS THAT THE
PURPOSE OF OUR HEARING TODAY
IT'S TO REVIEW THE PROGRESS HAS
BEEN MADE I UNDERSTAND THE
REASONS FOR IT- AND ALSO SEE
PLACES IN WHICH THINGS CAN BE.
DONE BETTER I WANT TO REFERENCE
THAT CHART THAT. PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN GIVEN HAS A HIGHLIGHT ON
TOP. AND THIS SHOWS THAT A LIST
OF THE CAMPUSES OF THE
UNIVERSITY. AND THEIR PROGRESS
IN MEETING THEIR GRADUATION
GOALS. AND ON THIS CHART YOU'LL
SEE- THAT STAND OUT SACRAMENTO
STATE IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
HAS HAD A HUNDRED AND 22%
IMPROVEMENT. SAN JOSE STATE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN.
PERCENT IMPROVEMENT- LONG BEACH
STATE HUNDRED AND 27%
IMPROVEMENT IN FIVE YEARS AND
THEIR FOUR YEAR GRADUATION
RATES THOSE ARE INCREDIBLE
GREAT PROGRESS POINTS AND WILL
LEARN ACT TODAY SOME OF THE
LESSONS FROM THOSE CAMPUSES IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING SO
RIGHT BUT ON THIS CHART YOU'LL
ALSO SEE SOME UNIVERSITIES THAT
HAVE. FALLEN SHORT. CAL STATE
EAST BAY WHICH IS IN MY NECK OF
THE WOODS IN FIVE YEARS THEIR
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE IS
ACTUALLY GONE DOWN FOURTEEN
PERCENT. BUT CHANNEL ISLANDS
GONE DOWN 4% TO PROGRESS IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION. SO WE HAVE
THIS COMBINATION OF INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS SYSTEM WIDE. FROM
19228% FOUR YEAR GRADUATION
RATES AND THAT INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUSES THAT EXCEED A 100%
IMPROVEMENT. AND THEN WE HAVE
SOME CAMPUS IS FALLING SHORT SO
I HOPE THAT. WE CAN DO TWO
THINGS TODAY WE CAN SEPARATE
OUR SUCCESS UNDERSTAND LESSONS
FROM THOSE EXPERIENCES ON THOSE
CAMPUSES. AND ALSO RECOMMIT AND
LEARN WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP
THE OTHERS DO EVEN BETTER. I
KNOW THE SYSTEM SET A HIGH GOAL
FOR THEM 40% FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE I KNOW WE CAN DO
BETTER THAN THAT. I KNOW THAT
WE'RE COMMITTED TO HELPING IT
TO BETTER THAN THAT. ALL RIGHT.
SO WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK
CENTER SENATE LABOR DO FOR
BEING HERE I THINK THEY'LL BE
SOME OTHER SUCH WILL JOIN IN
THE COURSE OF THIS HEARING WHEN
I. BEGIN THE PANEL THAT ONE
OFFER ANY MY COLLAR. OR TO THE
SAME ONE. WE START OKAY. OKAY
THREE. WELL I ONE OF THE
LEADERS OF THAT THE SYSTEM THE
I THIS IS. OF TO SUCCESS HAS
BEEN DONE JAMES MINOR HE'S
COMMITTED THE LAST FEW YEARS.
FORCEFULLY AND FOCUS TO HELPING
CAMPUSES DO BETTER AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU OUT THERE PART
OF OUR HEARINGS THAT WE'VE HAD
IN THE PAST WE WERE YOU
ATTENDED THE- HEARING WE HAD AT
POMONA. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND WE LOOK
FORTY YOUR THOUGHTS AND
COMMENTS ON ON THE ISSUE TODAY.
WELCOME THANK YOU SENATOR GOOD
AFTERNOON- SHE HEARD I'M JAMES
MINOR SERVICE THE- THE SYSTEM
VICE CHANCELLOR AND SENIOR
STRATEGIST AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY IN THE OFFICE
OF THE CHANCELLOR. I WANT TO
JUST TAKE A FEW MINUTES THIS
AFTERNOON TO GIVE YOU AN
OVERVIEW IN JUST A FEW DETAILS
ABOUT THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
WORK. AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT SOME
OF OUR SUCCESSES BUT ALSO SOME
OF OUR CONTINUING CHALLENGES.
AND THEN I'LL I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUES TO SHARE SOME
ABOUT THE CAMPUS EXPERIENCE AS
WE NEAR- THE HALF WAY MARK.
CAMPUSES ARE CONTINUING TO
IMPLEMENT AND REFINE THEIR
STUDENT SUCCESS PLANS WHILE
WELCOMING NEWLY HIGHER FACULTY
AND ADVISORS AND ROLLING
STUDENTS AN ADDITIONAL COURSE
SECTION AND IMPLEMENTING
EVIDENCE BASED STUDENT SUPPORT
PROGRAMS AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL
ARE SIX OPERATIONAL PRIORITIES-
ART WHICH ARE LISTED IN THE
HANDOUT THAT WE PROVIDE IT
CONTINUE TO DRIVE OUR WORK TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS OF THE
INITIATIVE TODAY I LIKE TO
TOUCH ON JUST THREE BROAD AREAS
FIRST AT THE PROGRESS. IN THE
SYSTEM WHILE UPDATE RESPECT TO
THE GRADUATION RATES SECOND OF
THE OVERALL. THE OVERVIEW OF
SOME PRACTICES THAT ARE
CONTRIBUTED THE GAINSTHAT
WE'RE SEEING IN THE GRADUATION
RATES AND THIRD AREAS OF FOCUS
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE MOMENTUM. FOR
SO FIRST THE PROGRESS OF DAY
THREE YEARS INTO THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE I AM PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT OUR- STUDENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANTRETURNS ON
INVESTMENT AS WE JUST HEARD.
FOR THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN ACADEMIC YEAR OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THOUSAND
BACHELOR'S DEGREES WERE EARNED
BY STUDENTS IN THE C. ISSUE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND ALL TOGETHER. THIS
RECORD NUMBER OF DEGREES
REPRESENTS TWENTY THOUSAND MORE
GRADUATES COMPARED TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN. WHICH WAS THE YEAR
BEFORE THE INITIATIVE WAS
LAUNCHED TO PUT THIS INTO
PERSPECTIVE SENATOR TWENTY
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL DEGREE
HOLDERS. EXCEEDS THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS CURRENTLY ATTENDING
CAL STATE EAST BAY SO IF YOU
COULD IMAGINE THE ENTIRE
STUDENT BODY CROSSING THE
COMMENCEMENT STAGE. ALONG WITH
SIX THOUSAND OF THEIR FRIENDS
IS THE IS THE IMAGE OF WE'RE
TRYING TO PROVIDE FOR YOU THIS
THIS AFTERNOON. THE SYSTEM WHY
GAINES WORD SHE WHILE THEY'RE
ROLLING MORE STUDENTS AND A
GREATER PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS
FROM UNDERSERVED. ALL WHILE
HOLDING THE LINE UP TO WHICH
WHICH IS PER MARK. TO REPORT
THAT THE GRADUATE TO RAY ARE AT
ALL TIME. IN VERGE EVERY COUNTY.
THE FOR YOUR GRAD RATE AS YOU
HEARD IS THAT TO EIGHT PER OF
FROM NINE WE CAN. WITH
CONTINUED INVESTMENT WERE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN STUDY PROGRESS
TOWARDS OUR GOAL OF GRADUATING
40% OF OUR FIRST TIME STUDENTS
IN FOUR YEARS. ALSO ON A
REFERENCE HERE THE SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATE IS THAT SIXTY
TWO PERCENT. AND I HOPE THIS
BECOMES ONE OF OUR TALKING
POINTS THIS EXCEEDS THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR PUBLIC
FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITIES WHICH IS
ALSO REMARKABLE SEVERAL
CAMPUSES ARE ALREADY MEETING OR
SO PASSED. THE SYSTEM WHY SIX
YEAR OLD. 70% FOR TRANSFERS. TO
YOUR GRADUATION RATE IS AT 41%
THE HIGHEST EVER FOR THE C.
ISSUE. AND THE FOR YOUR
TRANSFER GRADUATION RATE IS
THAT 78% ALSO THE HIGHEST EVER
FOR THE C. ISSUE. IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE TRANSFER
STUDENTS WHO MAY GRADUATE IN
TWO POINT FIVE OR EVEN THREE
YEARS AFTER ARRIVING IN ARE
INCLUDED IN THE FOUR YEAR RATE.
BEFORE THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TRANSFER STUDENT
COMPLETION RATES WERE ALREADY
AMONG THE HIGHEST IN THE NATION
COMPARED TO PEER INSTITUTIONS.
BUT WHAT CONTINUED INVESTMENT
FROM THE STATE AND STRATEGIC
FOCUS CAMPUSES HAVE ENHANCED
THEIR SUPPORT. FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS FURTHER AUGMENTING
THEIR SUCCESS WHICH IS
IMPORTANT SINCE 51% OF C. ISSUE
STUDENTS. ARE STARTED AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. NOW WHILE
THE UPTICK IN. PERCENTAGE POINT
GAMES MAY SEEM SMALL. OFTEN
HAVE TO REMIND LISTENERS THAT
EACH PERCENTAGE POINT GAIN AND
GRADUATION RATE REPRESENTS MORE
THAN A THOUSAND STUDENTS. SO A
JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW WE
GOT HERE THESE HISTORIC GAINES
DID NOT HAPPEN BY ACCIDENT.
THEY ARE THE RESULT OF
COLLABORATIVE IN STRATEGIC
THINKING IMPLEMENTATION OF
SYSTEM WHY POLICY CHANGES AND
FACULTY STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATORS BREAKING DOWN
INSTITUTIONAL SILOS AND
IMPLEMENTING CULTURAL AND
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES AIMED
DIRECTLY AT IMPROVING THE
EXPERIENCE OF OUR STUDENTS.
TODAY YOU'LL HEAR FROM
REPRESENTATIVES FROM SACRAMENTO
STATE AND SAN JOSE STATE ABOUT
THEIR SUCCESS AND THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE BUT ALL
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES COULD
TELL YOU A STORY ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE TAILORED APPROACH TO
INCREASING STUDENT SUCCESS IS
CONTRIBUTING TO GRADUATION
RATES. AND BETTER WITHIN THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE IS A
FUNDAMENTAL RECOGNITION THAT
LOCALIZATION AND THE IN NEED
AND THE NEED TO ACCOUNT FOR
VARIATIONS IN STUDENT
DEMOGRAPHICS AND CAMPUS NEEDS
AND TO DEVELOP CUSTOMIZED
APPROACH TO IMPLEMENTATION IS
IMPORTANT. WITH SAID THERE ARE
AFFECT THE PRICE IS THAT NEARLY
EVERY CAMPUSES WOMEN AT SUCH
BAND IN THE USE OF. TRYING AND
DIGITAL ADVISING TOOLS. SYSTEM
BY WE HAVE FIFTEEN FOR EXAMPLE
PARTICIPATING IN A STUDENT
SUCCESS COLLABORATIVE FOCUSED
ON ADVISING ANALYTICS THAT
IMPROVES THE USE AND SHARING OF
REAL TIME DATA TO MORE FOR
EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT STUDENT
SUCCESS IN SENDS WARNING SIGNS
TO STAFF. WHEN A STUDENT IS AT
RISK OF GETTING OFF TRACK. THIS
TECHNOLOGY IN THE HANDS OF
ADVISORS AND STUDENTS CAN HELP
STUDENTS MAKE MORE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR EDUCATION.
THE ADOPTION OF THESE DIGITAL
TO ARE CRITICAL TO GRADUATION
INITIATIVE BECAUSE IT
STREAMLINES ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS SEES ALLOWING ADVISORS
TO ENGAGE IN PROACTIVE
STRATEGIC CARE WHILE MONITORING
PROGRESS TOWARDS KEY ACADEMIC
MILESTONES. TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT LATER IF WE HAVE
THAT ARE IMPROVING OUR CAMPUS
SUCCESS SUCH AS IT CSU
NORTHRIDGE FOR EXAMPLE THE
CAMPUS IS PLACE A GRADUATION
RETENTION SPECIALIST IN THE
FINANCIAL AID OFFICE TO HELP
STUDENTS BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THEIR
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE. AND
THEIR COURSE SCHEDULE
DECISIONS. I ALSO LIKE TO TAKE
JUST A MOMENT TO ADDRESS THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM. AS
YOU KNOW CSU CAMPUSES EXCEED
THE NUMBER OF PROMISE PROGRAMS
MANDATED AN S. FOUR TWELVE WITH
THIRTEEN CAMPUSES CURRENTLY
OFFERING A FOR YOUR PLEDGE
PROGRAM. AND ALL BUT TWO ARE
FREE TO YOUR PLEDGE PROGRAM.
AND OPEN A MORE EFFECTIVE
ADVERTISE THE FOR A PROGRAM
STUDENTS ARE NOW DIRECTED TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM. THROUGH A TAB
ON THE CAL STATE APPLY WEBSITE
AND AS YOU KNOW THIS IS THE
WEBSITE WERE ALL SEE ISSUE
APPLICANTS. GO TO INTERACT AND
FILE THEIR APPLICATIONS CHANCE
OR WHITE IS ALSO DIRECTED SEE
ISSUE PRESIDENT'S TO CONTINUE
INCREASING THEIR EFFORTS TO
ADVERTISE THE PROGRAM TO NEW
STUDENTS PRIOR TO ENROLLMENT.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE C.
ISSUE WILL PROVIDE A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE THAT OUTLINES
THE RESULTS OF CAMPUS
PARTICIPATION AND THE PROMISE
PROGRAM AND THE RELATED STUDENT
OUTCOMES. WE SEE THIS IS ONE OF
SEVERAL EFFECTIVE EFFORTS BEING
EMPLOYED BY CAMPUSES TO MEET
OUR GRADUATION RATE GOALS.
UNDER THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WHAT'S NEXT
WELL WE'RE PROUD OF THE
GRADUATION RATE IMPROVEMENTS
FOR ALL STUDENTS FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS WE HAVE NOT YET
BEEN ABLE TO CLOSE THE EQUITY
GAP AND I WANT TO PAUSE HERE
BECAUSE- AN ACKNOWLEDGE THE
LEADERSHIP OF CHANCE WERE RIGHT
OUT. FAIR TO SAY THAT THE C.
ISSUE IS PROBABLY ONE OF A VERY
SMALL NUMBER OF SYSTEMS THAT
HAVE PUBLICLY DECLARED THE GOAL
OF COMPLETELY CLOSE IN THE
EQUITY GAP AND I THINK THAT'S
COMMENDABLE. THE FIRST AREA
THAT MUST FOCUS ON HOWEVER IS
EXPANDING OUR CONCERTED EFFORT
TO CLOSE EQUITY GAPS WE
CONTINUE TO IDENTIFY ACTIONS
THAT ARE GOOD FOR ALL STUDENTS.
YET THEY ALSO HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATELY POSITIVE
IMPACT. ON OUR MOST UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. THESE INCLUDE THE
ADAPTING IN AN EXPANDING SOME
OF OUR BEST PRACTICES UTILIZED
BY R. E. O. P. PROGRAMS SUCH AS
ACTIVE ADVISING SUMMER BRIDGE
STRUCTURE LEARNING SUPPORT AND
COAL HOARDING STUDENTS TO
INCREASE THEIR CHANCES OF BEING
A RETAIN. IT ALSO INCLUDES A
GREATER PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS
EARNING THIRTY CREDITS IN THE
FIRST YEAR AS WELL AS
COMPLETING THE MAP THEM AND
WRITTEN COMMUNICATIONS
REQUIREMENTS IN THEIR FIRST
YEAR IS A CRITICAL MILESTONE.
CLOSING THE EQUITY GAP ALSO
MEANS MAKING SYSTEMIC CHANGES
TO REDUCE BARRIERS FOR
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
STUDENT- AND NO STUDENTS FROM
THOSE FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. AS A RESULT OF THE
EFFORTS THAT BEGAN OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS. AS THEY
BECOME MORE INGRAINED ON OUR
CAMPUSES WE FIRMLY ANTICIPATE
THAT WE WILL SEE SIGNIFICANT
ERROR IN. EQUITY GAPS THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE WHEN THE
FIRST CORPS STUDENTS WHO
ENTERED UNDER THE ISSUES NEW
ACADEMIC PREPARATION POLICIES
BEGAN TO GRADUATE AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. OUR SECOND AREA OF
FOCUS SYSTEMICALLY IS IMPROVING
THE QUALITY OF ACADEMIC
ADVISING. FROM THE TIME A
STUDENT IS ADMITTED UNTIL THE
TIME A STUDENT CROSSES THE
COMMENCEMENT STAGE. CAMPUSES
ARE ALREADY IDENTIFIED WHAT
WORKS FOR THEIR STUDENTS TO
INSURE A CLEAR PATH TO DEGREE.
TO A DEGREE BEGINNING ON DAY
ONE. THIS INCLUDES GETTING NON
STATIC DEGREE PLANS IN THE
HANS OF STUDENTS BEFORE THEY
REGISTER FOR THEIR FIRST TERM.
IMPROVING DATA USAGE TO
OPTIMIZE COURSE SCHEDULING AND
TO INCREASE TIMELY
COMMUNICATION WITH STUDENTS
ABOUT THEIR PROGRESS AND
NAVIGATING THE REMAINING
REQUIREMENTS. THE THIRD AND
FINAL AREA THAT I WANT TO
MENTION ALL IS PROMOTING
STUDENT SUCCESS AND ADDRESS
SOME BASIC NEEDS.THEIR NUMBER
EFFORTS- TO RESPOND TO MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS AND CREATIVE
AND INNOVATIVE WAYS SUCH AS
DEVELOPING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. LAST APRIL THAT
SEE ISSUE HELD A CONFEENCE
WERE CAMPUS MENTAL HEALTH TEAMS
AND COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. CAME TOGETHER TO
FIND WAYS TO BETTER MEET THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. IN ADDITION TO
ESTABLISHING COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS CAMPUSES ARE ALSO
INVESTING AND HIRING MORE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
BETWEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALL TO
NINETEEN THE HEART AND SO NET
NEW TIME MENTAL HEALTH. ADDED
ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND YET WE
KNOW WE HAVE MUCH MORE TO. ONLY
INSULAR ARE THE CHANCE WAS OFF
IS ISSUE GRAN TO QUE THIS WITH
THE A- MAIL PROVIDE BY THE
STATE FOR BASIC. EMERGENCY
HOUSING AND MENTAL HEALTH AND
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. IN THEIR
PROPOSALS CAMPUSES HIGHLIGHTED
A EXCITING PLANS TO DEVELOP AND
EXPAND EXTERNAL BASIC NEEDS
PARTNERSHIPS HELPING TO MAKE
SURE THE STUDENTS HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT NEEDED TO
BE SUCCESSFUL. THESE THREE
AREAS- BUT I JUST HIGHLIGHTED
ARE IMPORTANT. THEY'RE NOT
EXHAUSTIVE BUT THEY'RE
IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE OUR
GRADUATION RATE PROGRESS I
THINK WE HAVE SAID FROM THE
BEGINNING THIS WILL LIKELY NOT
BE A LINEAR PROCESS BUT WE HAVE
TO SUSTAIN MOMENTUM IF WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE
GAINES. AND GRADUATE FROM RATES
AND CLOSE IN THE EQUITY GAPS.
IN MANY RESPECTS. INCREASING
GRADUATION RATE DOES MEAN MORE
STUDENTS TAKEN THIRTY UNITS PER
YEAR. AND TO ACCOMPLISH THIS WE
MUST HAVE MORE CLASSES AND MORE
FACULTY TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
CAN A ROLL AND THE CLASSES THEY
NEED WHEN THEY NEED THEM.
CURRENTLY THE AVERAGE UNIT LOW
FOR UNDERGRADUATES IS THIRTEEN
POINT FOUR UNITS. TO INCREASE
THIS AMOUNT TO FOURTEEN JUST TO
GO FROM THIRTEEN POINT FOUR TO
FOURTEEN WHAT REQUIRE. A
RECURRING INVESTMENT OF A
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO HIRE ADDITIONAL
INSTRUCTION OR INSTRUCTORS AND
TO OFFER THE COURSES NECESSARY
FOR OUR STUDENTS. SENATOR GO
FROM FOURTEEN UNITS TO FIFTEEN
UNITS BY OUR CALCULATIONS
SYSTEM WHY. IS ROUGHLY FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS A RECURRING FUNDING. AS
WE ETER THE FOURTH YEAR OF THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE- THE DATA
SHOW THAT WE CONTINUE TO MAKE A
PROGRESS. RECORD HIGH
GRADUATION RATES AND THE MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
THOUSAND GRADUATES ARE
TESTAMENT TO WHAT CAN BE
ACHIEVED THROUGH INVESTING IN
OUR STUDENTS OUR CAMPUSES AND
THE SEA ISSUE. THIS YEAR THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES HAS REQUESTED
A HUNDRED AND FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
THIS AMOUNT INCLUDES. THE
FOURTH OF SIX INSTALLMENTS OF
THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THAT WAS REQUESTED
AND CONVERTING THE ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TO OWN ONGOING. THIS
INVESTMENT HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
CRITICAL. A CLASS THAT WILL
DETERMINE OUR SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATE. AND OUR EQUITY
GAP GOALS ARE ON OUR CAMPUSES
TODAY. FINALLY THE STUDENTS
LIKE ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
DESERVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
REACH THEIR DEGREE GOALS AND TO
PURSUE A BRIGHT FUTURE FOR
THEMSELVES THEIR FAMILY AND FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU DOCTOR
MINOR AND- **** THE PROGRESS
REPORT AND ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT YOU IN A CHANCE OR IN YOUR
WHOLE TAM HAS BEEN INVOLVED
WITH- CENTER ROTH QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER I APOLOGIZE- I
HAVE WILL HAVE TO LEAVE IN A
MINUTE TO I HAVE TO COMMITTEES
MEETING AT THE SAME TIME BUT-
LET ME ASK AND HAVE LOTS OF
QUESTIONS INCLUDING ON MENTAL
HEALTH INSURANCE BUT LET ME AS
THE ONE THE- THREE MOST
PERTINENT TO THIS CONVERSATION
STUDENT SUCCESS ENCOURAGED. TO
NEST WITH ACADEMIC COUNSELING
AND ADVISING ANSWER YOU
MENTIONED IT IN YOUR INITIAL
PRESENTATION. SO MY QUESTION IS
THIS. IS THE SYSTEM ADEQUATELY
FUNDED. FOR ACADEMIC COUNSELING
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM. I GUESS
I HAVE ANOTHER DOES THIS. AS A
SYSTEM PUT IN A REQUEST THAT
CONTAINS ADEQUATELY FUNDED
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR ACADEMIC
COUNSELING IF IT'S EMBEDDED IN
YOUR STUDENT SUCCESS BCP. AND
IF NOT WHAT IS THE NUMBER AND
IF YOU CAN'T PROVIDED TODAY WE
WILL HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
IN A FEW WEEKS BUT I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN THAT BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT FOR FOCUSED ON
STUDENT SUCCESS AND GRADUATING
KEY TO THAT IS ACADEMIC
EFFECTIVE ACADEMIC COUNSELING
AND PART OF IT MAY BE THE
ELECTRONIC OPERATE. IN THAT YOU
REFERENCED IN YOUR PRESENTATION
BUT THERE'S PROBABLY NO
SUBSTITUTE. TO FACE TO FACE
CONVERSATION WITH THE CANCER
WHO KNOWS WHAT HE OR SHE IS
DOING. YES THANK YOU SENATOR
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO THE
SHORT ANSWER HOWEVER IS NOW A
WE ARE NOT ADEQUATELY FUNDED TO
PROVIDE THE NUMBER OF ACADEMIC
ADVISERS FOR OUR STUDENTS THERE
IS AN INDUSTRY STANDARD WERE
FAR FROM IT. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT IS SOLD THE APPROACH HAS
BEEN TO GO AS FAR AS WE CAN
WITH HIRING INDIVIDUALS WE KNOW
THAT IS ONE OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE THINGS WE DO IS A
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. BUT TO TRY
TO AUGMENT THAT WITH- BETTER
AND MORE EFFICIENT USE OF
DIGITAL ADVISING TOOLS ARE WE
KNOW THAT MOST OF OUR STUDENTS
ARRIVE WITH THE SMART ONE AND
SELL SOME OF THIS IS CAN WE-
I'M BETTER MORE. BILL TO
INFORMATION TO THE ABOUT THE
CHOICES OF SCHEDULE. AND TO
BAIL THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN
SO ONCE WE GIVE A STUDENT GREAT
ADVICE ABOUT WHAT TO DO. SHE OR
HE HAS TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
DO IT ON THE CAMPUS AND A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THIS MARRIAGE
BETWEEN. BETTER AND MORE
EFFECTIVE COUNSELING. AND
ADDITIONAL COURSE SECTIONS AN
ADDITIONAL FACULTY A FIRE AS A
STUDENT I COULD POPULATE MY
SCHEDULE. BUT IF THE COURSES
ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO ME WHEN I
NEED THEM- DOESN'T MATTER HOW
GOOD THE OR THE QUALITY OF THE
ADVICE IS THAT THE INSTITUTION
HAS TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
STUDENTS. ACCORDING TO THEIR
NEEDS SO. WE ALL WORKED OUT THE
NUMBER- MAY OF OUR QUE AS HAVE
USED A PORTION. GRADUATION
INITIATIVE FAR HIGHER
ADDITIONAL ACADEMIC COUNSELORS-
AND AMPUS PRESIDENTS HAVE MADE
THOSE DECIIONS AND THAT AMOUNT
VARIES ACROSS THE CAMPUS. BUT I
THINK IT IS A VERY WELL KNOWN
FACT. THAT NUMBER AND RATIO. OF
COUNSEL TO STUDENTS THIS SIMPLY
NOT ADEQUATE. WELL I WANT TO
RESPECT THE BCP PROCESS AND THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE ON
THIS FLOOR IN THE FLOORS ABOVE
US WITH THE FIRST FLOOR. BUT I
WILL BE ASKING THE QUESTION IN
A COUPLE WEEKS. TO WHAT EXACTLY
WE WOULD DO IS A LEGISLATURE.
VIS A VIS THE C. ISSUE ISTOM.
TO ADEQUATELY FUND AT ACADEMIC
COUNSELING ACROSS THE BOARD SO
THAT STUDENTS WHO NEED
COUNSELING HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GET IT. AND GET IT WITHIN A
REASONABLE PERIOD OF TIME
BECAUSE IT OCCURS TO ME.
ALTHOUGH I'M DECADES AND
DECADES REMOVED FROM THE
ACADEMIC SETTING. THAT IF A
STUDENT MAKES A MISTAKE.
BECAUSE A STUDENT CAN ACCESS A
COUNSELOR OR OF THE CANCER
MAKES A MISTAKE BECAUSE THE
CANCER DOESN'T KNOW NECESSARILY
BUT HERE SHE HAPPENS TO BE
DOING IN THAT AND A PARTICULAR
INSTANCE. IT CAN COST STOOPED
AND KISSED HIM ONE TWO THREE OR
FOUR SEMESTERS. OF A STUDENT'S
PRESENCE ON CAMPUS WHEN THE
STUDENT MIGHT NEST MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO GRADUATE
EIGHT. FREE UP SEAT FOR ELSE SO
I. ASKING THE QUESTION. NOT TO
GET WINTER. WITH FIRST FOR NBC
PROCESS BUT IT WILL BE A
LEGISLATIVE QUESTION AND THE
QUESTION OF BRITAIN'S WOULD
LOVE TO KNOW THE NUMBER SO.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR PATIENCE. GREAT
THANK YOU SENATOR ROBB CENTER
LEYVA. THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER
OF FIFTY DOT MINOR FOR THAT
VERY COMPREHENSIVE REPORT. MY
QUESTION IS ALSO FINANCIAL IN
NATURE. IF WE ONLY INCREASED
FUNDING BY WHAT PERCENT I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THE CHAIRS. BUT YOU
WERE ABLE TO GREG. RATES FROM
928% HOW DID DO THAT WITH A STE.
I MEAN SERIOUSLY HOW DID YOU DO
THAT WITH SUCH A SMALL AMOUNT
OF MONEY. YEAH SO IT'S SO IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION I WILL TELL
YOU THAT EVERY INTERVENTION
THAT WE HAVE. EMPLOYED OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS NOT ALL OF
THEM WERE COST INTENSIVE. SOL
IT JUST JUST FOR A POINT OF
REFERENCE SENATOR WHEN WE BEGAN
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE AND
WE WERE ATTEMPTING TO IDENTIFY
APPROPRIATE TARGETS FOR THE
SYSTEM. AND FOR EACH OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS- WE BEGAN WHAT
PEER INSTITUTIONS. WE CAN
COMPARE YOU KNOW HARVARD AND
STANFORD A YEAR WE WENT TO FIND
A REGIONAL PUBLIC FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS THAT ROOM ROLLING
SIMILAR STUDENTS TO TAR SEE
ISSUE POPULATION. WE FOUND TWO
THINGS ONE THAT- PER PUPIL
SPENDING WAS WAS FAR DIFFERENT.
BUT WE ALSO LEARNED THAT THERE
WERE SOME STRUCTURAL
DIFFERENCES IN TERMS OF HOW ALL
CAMPUSES WERE GOING ABOUT-
ADVISING STUDENTS REGISTERING
THEM FROM CLASSES SO I. I THINK
WHAT'S IMPORTANT HERE WE HAVE-
WE HAVE IT WE HAVE OUT SIZE OR
OUTPERFORM BASED ON THE
INVESTMENT. BUT I THINK SOMEONE
ARTICULATED THIS WAY THAT WE'VE
PICKED ALL OF THE LOW HANGING
FRUIT. AND THEN SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WILL REQUIRE MORE
INTENSIVE INVESTMENT PEOPLE.
ADDITIONAL COUNSELORS MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS ADDITIONAL
FACULTY- ADDITIONS AND PHYSICAL
SPACE TO OFFER ADDITIONAL
COURSES THOSE ITEMS WILL BE.
NOT ONLY ONGOING COST BUT ALSO
MUCH MORE COST INTENSIVE. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU AND WOULD YOU
SAY THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT I
KNOW ALL OF IT'S IMPORTANT BUT
WOULD YOU SAY THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WOULD BE TO
HIRE ADDITIONAL FACULTY SO THAT
YOU CAN OPEN MORE CLASS
SECTIONS. THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT I HEAR FROM STUDENTS ALL
THE TIME IS THAT I CAN'T GET
THE CLASS I NEED UNTIL NEXT
SEMESTER OR THE FOLLOWING
SEMESTER INTO RICHARD'S POINT
THAT AND THEN IT KEEPS THEM IN
SCHOOL LONGER AND IT DOESN'T
FOR A SEAT FOR SOMEONE ELSE. SO
I THINK THE SHORT ANSWER IS YES
ONE OF QUALIFY MY YES IF I MAY.
AND YOU KNOW MY PROFESSIONAL
OPINION IS THAT YES THAT IS
TRUE BUT BUT THE OTHER SIDE OF
THAT EQUATION IS REALIZING A
GREATER SENSE OF EFFICIENCY.
AND HOW WE USE AND ACCESS THE
AVAILABLE COURSES IN THE COURSE
SCHEDULE. SO I THINK IT'S A
COMBINATION OF BOTH YES WE NEED
MORE VOLUME WE NEED MORE
CAPACITY BUT I WILL SAY WE ALSO
HAVE TO INCREASE THE EFFICIENCY
IN THAT INTERACTION BETWEEN OUR
COURSE SCHEDULE AND THE CHOICES
THAT STUDENTS MAKE THAT LEAD TO
ACADEMIC PROGRESS. VERY GOOD
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR-LEYVA- I WANNA HAD MENTIONED-
ANOTHER CHART THIS IN YOUR
INFORMATIONAL MATERIAL IT TALKS
ABOUT HOW MANY UNITS STUDENTS
ARE TAKING- AT THE CSU. AND
COUPLE FACTOIDS THAT COME OUT
OF THAT. PARTLY ANSWERS US IN
EARLY THIS QUESTION BUT- IS
THAT 87% THIS TO THAT THE CSU
TO TAKE A FULL LOAD. OF UNITS
FOR MORE. I'D OBVIOUSLY EVERY
STUDENT IS IN A UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE THEY COULD WORK
OBLIGATIONS FAMILY OBLIGATIONS
BUT- THE STUDENTS THAT ARE IN
THE CSU FOR THE MOST PART ARE
TRYING TO GET THROUGH. AS
QUICKLY AS THEY CAN. AND THE
BIGGEST PROGRESS POINT ON THIS
BECAUSE THAT EIGHTY SEVEN
PERCENT. I HAS INSISTED OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS TAKING
TWELVE ANSWER BUT THE CHANGES
THOSE WERE TAKING FIFTEEN. OR
MORE. YOU MAY HEAR FROM
CAMPUSES IN AMMAN. THAT NUMBER
HAS IN FROM AROUND LOW THIRTIES
TO NOW FORTY THREE PERCENT. AND
WE KNOW THAT IF THEY JUST TAKE
FIFTEEN UNITS. AND THEY TAKE IN
THE RIGHT UNITS ON THEIR MAJOR.
THAT THAT'S NOT A SET COST
ELEMENT DIRECTLY BUT IT'S ABOUT
TRYING TO KEEP HIM ON TRACK
YEAH- ON THE COURSE THAT THEY
NEED TO BE ON TO GET THROUGH IN
pFOUR YEARS. OKAY WELL WE HAVE-
THANK YOU DOCTOR MILLER STATE
SAY TUNE I KNOW I HAVE SOME
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS BUT I WANT
TO WAIT TO OUR OTHER PANELISTS
OF. HAVE I SPOKEN. WELL WE DO
HAVE SOME LEADERS FROM TWO OF
OUR CAMPUS IS HERE TO SHARE
THEIR- INSIGHTS IT'S AT
SACRAMENTO AND SAN JOSE BOTH OF
WHICH HAVE REALLY SHOWN
TREMENDOUS. IMPROVEMENT AND WE
WERE A AND EXCITED. ABOUT THEIR-
THEIR WORK THERE AND THEIR
INNOVATIONS THAT THEY HAVE. TO
PLAY. BUT DOCTOR STEVE. THE
PROVOST FROM CALIFORNIA.
SACRAMENTO IS HERE. AND DOCTOR
STILL YEAH I DODD KNOWS
PRONOUNCED THAT RIGHT. THE VICE
BOAST OF UNDERGRADUATE AT. THE
SENATE STATE UNIVERSITY. ARE
HERE TO SHARE THIS STORY WITH
US. AND I DON'T KNOW ONCE FIRST
ATTACK. THANK AND FOR YOUR
MONEY. THANK YOU. GEN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR US HERE
IT'S A TO PUT OF TELL YOU
LITTLE BIT ABOUT EXCITED I MY
NAME'S. PRESS THE PROVO FROM
SAT. STATE AND I'M PLEASED TO
ROOF PORT BACK TO YOU ON THE
PROGRESS BEING MADE AT
SACRAMENTO STATE TO IMPROVE OUR
GRADUATION RATES AND REDUCE OUR
TREATMENT. BEFORE I BEGIN I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER FOR BRINGING MANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
SACRAMENTO STATE LAST MAY- WE
ENJOY THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
WITH YOU HOW WE'RE IMPROVING
STUDENT SUCCESS A MEETING OR
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS- AND-
EACH. OF YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
CSU SACRAMENTO STATE AND OUR
STUDENTS IS GREATLY APPRECIATED
BY OUR ENTIRE. CAMPUS
COMMUNITY. I DIDN'T LEARN I WAS
GONNA BE HERE TILL- LAST WEEK-
BUT I HAVE LITERALLY BEEN
EXCITED TO TELL A STORY FOR
YEARS SO I COULDN'T BE MORE.
ARTICLE TO BE HERE I'M VERY
PROUD OF. WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
A VERY PRIVILEGED TO BE ABLE TO
SERVICE THE PROVOST. SACRAMENTO
STATE I'VE BEEN DOING THAT FOR
ABOUT A YEAR. BUT I BET ON
CAMPUSES TWO THOUSAND ONE SO
IT'S DRAMATIC CHANGES LAST.
HANDFUL OF YEARS. WE'RE NOT
FIVE YEARS INTO A CULTURE
CHANGE AND SYSTEM'S CHANGE.
THAT ARE TRYING TO ENCOURAGE US
TO TAKE A FULL COURSE LOAD.
WHICH WE WOULD SAY WE WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT FIFTEEN MINUTES-
BECAUSE THAT WILL GET OUR
STUDENTS. AND FOUR. ENSURE THE
COURSES ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM
AND PORT ACT. FOR PERSONAL. I
DO. SIX ALWAYS BEEN OUR MISSION
ALWAYS WILL BE QUESTION. THE%
CHANGE POCKET. IS WHO ARE NOW.
ACTIVELY AND- WITH C. OUT NEW
WAYS SUPPORT UR STOOD SUCCESS.
THERE ARE COMING BACK. AND ARE
VERY PROMISING AND SHOW THAT WE
MUST CONTINUE ON THE PATH THAT
WE ARE ON. OUR FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN FOR YOUR GRAD RATE
WENT FROM EIGHT POINT 5% AND
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY POINT
3% FOUR SIX YOUR READ RATE FOR
FIRST TIME STUDENTS WENT FROM
FORTY SIX PERCENT. TO FIFTY
FOUR POINT 8% TO YOUR GRAD
RATE- FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS
WENT FROM TWENTY FIVE POINT SIX
TO FORTY TWO POINT TWO PERCENT.
AND THE TRANSFER FOR YOUR
TRANSFER RATE- FROM SEVENTY ONE
TO SEVENTY SEVEN PERCENT. WE
ACHIEVE THESE RESULTS IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS AS WELL AS SOME
OTHER RESULTS ON A TALK ABOUT
HERE IN A SECOND. FIRST OF ALL
WE REALLY WANTED TO LOOK AT
CHANGING THE MENTALITY OF
EVERYBODY ON CAMPUS AND ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS THAT WERE COMING
IN. BY SAYING OUT LOUD WE YOU
YOU CAN FINISH IN FOUR AND SO
WE HAVE A PHOENICIAN FOR
PROGRAM IN THE THROUGH INTO
PROGRAM. WHERE STUDENTS WHO
COME IN AND COMMIT TO TAKING
FIFTEEN UNITS. SIGNING UP AND
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETING THIRTY
UNITS CAN BE PART OF THIS
PROGRAM. FOR SIMILAR TO OUR
CALIFORNIA PROMISE I'LL TALK
ABOUT OUR NUMBERS HERE IN A
SECOND FACTORY A VERY LARGE
NUMBER CALIFORNIA. PROMISE
STUDENTS THAT ARE ALSO PART OF
THIS PHOENICIAN FOR. PROGRAM
WHAT WE SEE IS IN CHANGING THAT
MINDSET AND IN FACT GOING TO WE
HAVE WE TALK TO OUR ACADEMIC
ADVISORS AND SAYING. WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT HOW DO WE GET YOU
INTO FIVE CLASSES ARE FIFTEEN
UNITS INSTEAD OF. TWELVE UNITS
ARE NINE UNITS. IN CHANGE THAT
MINDSET 80% OF OUR FRESHMAN NOW
PLEDGE TO TAKE A FULL COURSE
LOAD. THAT'S UP FROM 62% IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. 73% OF OUR
FRESHMAN NOW TAKE FIFTEEN UNITS
IN THE FIRST SEMESTER AND
THAT'S UP 425% IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. SO IT'S BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT BY
GETTING OUT FRONT OF THEM WHEN
THEY COME FOR IN TATIAN AS WE
GET THEM RIGHT THERE ON CAMPUS
AND TALK TO THEM ABOUT WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE. ABLE TO GET
THROUGH. OUR CALVET THE PROBLEM
PROGRAM. IN OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
IS THAT'S ALRIGHT THE COMING
ROAD THAT WAS AT YOUR IDEA THE
NAME THE COMPANY PROMISED IT
IT'S A TERM THAT USED THAT
DESCRIBE LOTS OF THINGS THAT
ARE LIFE AND SO. BUT IT WAS THE
TERM USED IN THE LEGISLATION
YES OKAY OKAY. AS MANY OTHER
GREAT THINGS WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS ONE OF THEM
AND WE'RE SEEING THE RESULTS ON
OUR CAMPUSES WELL WE HAVE OVER
SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT ARE
PART OF THE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW
AND- WE HAVE OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND THAT ARE IN OUR
PHOENICIAN FOR PROGRAM- AND
AGAIN PLEASE KNOW THAT THE
MAJORITY OF OUR- SIX THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA PROMISE STUDENTS ARE
ALSO IN THE- DEFINITION FOR-
AND- AND THAT ELEVEN THOUSAND
IS BOTH- FINISHING FOURTH
THROUGH INTO PROGRAM SO WE- ARE
ALSO LOOKING AT- TRANSFER
STUDENTS. IN FALL TWENTY TWENTY
SECOND A STATE WILL MERGE ARE
TWO PROGRAMS TOGETHER SO THAT
ALL THE BENEFITS OF EACH OF BE
ABLE TO. ACCRUE TO THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE PART OF IT- WE
EXPECTED OVERALL PARTICIPATION
RATE OF ABOUT 60% OR EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY HAS WE MOVE INTO
OUR FALL SEMESTER AND AS WE
START BUILDING OUR SCHEDULES
FOR UPCOMING FALL SEMESTER WILL
WORK ON A NEW STRATEGIC
SCHEDULING PROCESS. WHERE ARE
INCOMING STUDENTS ARE GOING TO
BE GIVEN A FIFTEEN MINUTE. LOAD
BEFORE THEY GET THERE WITH
COURSES THAT HAVE BEEN CHOSEN
BY THE FACULTY IN THE PROGRAMS
AT THEIR END TO SET THEM UP FOR
THE HIGHEST PROBABILITY OF
SUCCESS- THIS IS DOE IT'S OVER
OTHER CAMPUSES ALREADY AND
WE'RE JUST. WE'RE WE'RE GONNA
BE IMPLEMENTING THAT THIS
COMING YEAR. ENCOURAGING SO TO
TAKE A FULL COURSE LOAD ONLY
WORKS AS JAMES SAID IF THE
COURSES ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
WE'VE MADE IT A PRIORITY AND
WE'VE MADE A VERY STRONG
PRIORITY WE'VE CHANGED OUR
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS BY THE WAY
WE DO OUR BUDGET AND THE WAY WE
ALLOCATE. OUT MONEY TO COLLEGES
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PRIORITY
IS. THAT WE HAVE FACULTY THERE
WE HAVE COURSES THERE ARE
AVAILABLE TO OUR STUDENTS.
WE'VE HIRED A NET INCREASE OF
EIGHTY THREE TENURE TRACK
FACULTY- THAT'S AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR RETIREMENT AND
OTHER SEPARATIONS WITHOUT
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED TENURE TRACK-HIGHER SINCE- TWENTY FOURTEEN.
FIFTEEN WE'VE ADDED MORE THAN
ELEVEN HUNDRED NEW COURSE
SECTIONS WHICH MEANS WERE UP TO
NINETY THREE HUNDRED COURSE
SECTIONS FROM EIGHTY TWO
HUNDRED. COURSE SECTIONS.
THAT'S IN OVER 10% INCREASE
INSTRUCTIONAL CAPACITY. FACTORY
WERE HIRING AND COURSE
ADDITIONS OF HELP US REDUCE IF
NOT ELIMINATE IN ALMOST ALL
AREAS THE NUMBER OF BOTTLENECK
COURSES. THERE OFTEN STALLED-
AND OF OFF INSTALLED THE
PROGRESS OF OUR STUDENTS TO
IT'S GONNA GRAY. MY OFFICE USED
TO GET DOZENS OF CALLS- IN FACT
AND I THINK IT'S FALL OF. ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS. BEFORE THE
FALL SEMESTER STARTED SAYING-
LET US KNOW IF YOU THERE'S A
CLASS THAT YOU NEED IN. A WE
GOT A LOT OF EMAILS- GOT
HUNDREDS OF THEM. LAST SEMESTER
I GOT ONE- THIS MUST'VE HAD A
HANDFUL MORE AND I'M I'M NOT
LOSING MY SLEEP AND FIGURE OUT
WHY IT'S GONE UP SINCE LAST
SEMESTER- SO THE PROGRESS HAS
BEEN DRAMATIC. I WAS GONNA ASK
A CENTER LABOR I HOPE TO STOOD
SHE'S HEARING FROM OR NOT FROM
OUR AREA BECAUSE I HOPE THEY'RE
NOT ON OUR CAMPUS- WE STILL
HAVE SOME ISSUES AND THEIR
IDIOSYNCRATIC MOVE AROUND
PENDING ON. WHAT WE HAVE
AVAILABILITY OF INSTRUCTORS AND
LECTURES TO BE ABLE FILL
SECTIONS. THAT WE NEED. WE KNOW
THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE BUSY AND
OFTEN HAVE COMPETING DEMANDS IN
AND OUT OF THE CLASSROOM.
THEREFORE WE'VE ENCOURAGED OUR
STUDENTS TO UTILIZE SUMMER
SESSION. TO CATCH UP AND STAY
ON TRACK AND GET HAVE IN THEIR
STUDIES. WE OFFER WHAT WE CALL
A PROVOST SUMMER GRADUATION
ASSISTANCE GRANTS. IS GRANTS
ARE UP TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND ARE TARGETED TOWARDS
STUDENTS NEAR GRADUATION OR WHO
NEED SUMMER SCHOOL. OR SUMMER
SESSION TO GET TO THIRTY UNITS
IN THE ACADEMIC YEAR. WE NOW
HAVE MORE THAN A THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS TAKING
SUMMER SESSION. EACH YEAR WHEN
THIS YEAR WE HAD. THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS- IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE HAVE THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS THIS YEAR AND
FORTY SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS.
ALLOCATED MORE THAN. TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROVENCE
GRANTS OF THE LAST THREE YEARS.
AND MORE THAN- TWENTY NINE
HUNDRED STUDENTS TO RECEIVE
SUCH GRANTS. MOST OF THIS ARE
MUCH OF THIS IS COME FROM OUR
GI TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. FUNDING
AND SHOWN DRAMATIC RESULTS IN
GETTING STUDENTS TO TAKE
CLASSES THAT'LL HELP THEM. MOVE
ALONG. WITH IMPROVED ARE
ADVISING EFFORTS- BY HIRING
ACADEMIC ADVISORS FELT. IT
RISING CENTERS IN EACH COLLEGE.
PROACTIVELY REACHING OUT TO
STUDENTS AND WE CAN USE A LOT
OF TECH. G. TWO. DOWN STUDENTS
THAT ARE EITHER GOING BEHIND.
NEED TO BE READY. FOR BUT WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO PROACTIVELY
REACH OUT TO THEM ON INDIVIDUAL
BASIS AND SAY. WE NOTICED THAT
YOU ARE ON TRACK BUT YOU'RE NOT
IN THIS CLASS THAT WE HAVE
SEATS AND- ARE YOU INTERESTED
IN BEING OUT OF THAT SO WERE
WERE USING OUR COLLEGE SUCCESS
CENTERS TO REACH OUT TO
STUDENTS. ON A PERSON BY PERSON
BASIS. I WE'VE GOT DIRECT
SERVICES MENTORING FOR
DIFFERENT STUDENT GROUPS AND WE
USE STUDENT MENTORS AND STUDENT
TUTORS TO HELP SUPPLEMENT. OUR
SHORTFALL IN ACADEMIC ADVISORS
THAT WERE EXPERIENCING
EVERYWHERE. AS I SAID WE'RE
ALSO EXPERIMENTING WITH
STRATEGIC SCHEDULING OR WE'RE
CERTAIN THAT THAT'S GONNA MAKE
A BIG DIFFERENCE. MUCH OF WHAT
WE HAVE DONE COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN DONE WITHOUT INVESTING IN
TECHNOLOGY ECOSYSTEM- DATA
DESERVED. DECISION DATA DRIVEN
DECISION MAKING TO IMPROVE
CAMPUS EFFICIENCIES AND THE
STUDENT EXPERIENCE WE'VE GOT A-
AN ECOSYSTEM OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT TALK TO EACH
OTHER THAT HELP US LOOK AT
WHAT. STUDENTS NEEDS ARE WHERE
THEY ARE IN THEIR DEGREE
PROGRAM- WHERE THEY ARE ALREADY
SAID THAT THEY WANT TO TAKE
COURSES AND THEN WE FEED THAT
TO OUR DEPARTMENT CHAIRS. TO
MAKE SURE OF THOSE COURSES ARE
THERE AVAILABLE TO THEM WHEN
THEY NEED THEM AND SO. WE'VE
WE'VE TAKEN A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO GET THEM
TOGETHER AND TALK AND GET THE
INFORMATION WE NEED TO GET OUR
STUDENTS WHAT THEY NEED- WHEN
THEY NEED IT. WE'RE ALSO
EXCITED ABOUT OUR PROGRESS- AND
PAYING SPECIAL ATTENTION TO
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP IS
A MORAL IMPERATIVE ON ALL OF
OUR CAMPUSES. WE CLOSED OUR ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY GAP-
FOR THE SIX YEAR GRADUATION
RATE AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN- THAT
CLOSURE OPEN BACK UP AGAIN-
LAST YEAR. AND WHEN WE LOOKED
BACK. WE THINK IT WAS A COHORT
OF STUDENTS THAT THAT WE GOT
THAT CAME TO US THIS IS OUR SIX
YEAR GRAD RATE. THAT CAME TO
US- BEFORE WE STARTED OUR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE PLANS
THAT WE LOST THEM BEFORE WE
COULD EVER REALLY. INTERACT
WITH THEM WITH OUR NEW SYSTEMS
AND SO WE THINK WE'RE BACK ON
TRACK AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
THAT GOING BACK DOWN AGAIN
STARTING NEXT YEAR. FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES FOR A NUMBER
OF STUDENT ETHNIC AND SOCIO
ECONOMIC COHORTS OF GREATLY
IMPROVED. THE RISING TIDE IS
LIFTING ALL BOATS. I'M GONNA
NOTICES PICK TWO OR THREE BUT
I'M NOT ON A PECKHAM LL
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL REALLY
GOOD- IF WE LOOK AT FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES THEY'VE
TRIPLED FOR MANY GROUPS OR
SPANDEX STUDENTS WAS. EIGHT
POINT 6% IS NOW TWENTY POINT
ONE PERCENT. ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER WAS FIVE AND A
HALF PERCENT IT'S NOT SIXTEEN
POINT 3% AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS FOR YOUR GRADUATION
RATE WAS FOUR POINT 3% IT'S NOT
TWELVE POINT SEVEN PERCENT.
PALATABLE STUDENTS WAS FIVE
POINT 5% NOW 16% FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS WENT FROM
FOUR POINT SEVEN TO A SEVENTEEN
POINT ONE. AND OUR MALE
STUDENTS WENT FROM SIX POINT
SIX TO FIFTEEN POINT ONE. SO
ACROSS ALL- WAIT THAT WE LOOK
AT IT GRADUATION RATES HAVE
INCREASED. BUT THEY STILL-PERSIST AT LOWER RATES THAN WE
WANT THEM TO BE IN LOWER RATES
THAN OTHER COHORTS OF STUDENTS
THAT WE HAVE. AND WE'RE DOING%
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ELIMINATE
THOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. OUR
EFFORTS OF BETA SO NATIONAL
MODELS IN AT IN MANY WAYS WERE
PLEASE BY THE RECOGNITION WE
RECEIVED WE GOT AND ASK YOU
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF STATE
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES
EXCELLENCE. IN INNOVATION
AWARD- BUT WE'RE ONLY GETTING
STARTED- WE'RE VERY VERY
EXCITED ABOUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO. AS OUR EFFORTS ARE
SUSTAIN FOR THE FRESHMEN AND
TRANSFER STUDENTS ARRIVE ON OUR
CAMPUS THIS FALL. UNDER THE
CLASS OF TWENTY TWENTY BANNER
WELCOMING THEM WE'RE PROUD THE
ENVIRONMENT WE'VE CREATED FORM.
IS THE FIRST FULL YEAR OF
STUDENTS IN ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
WILL BE. IMPACTED BY THE
EFFORTS THAT WE'VE MADE OVER
THE LAST FOUR YEARS- AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING THE
RESULTS. HERE'S THE PART THAT-
I ADDED IN ALL THIS IS A STORY
BEEN LOOKING FOR TO TOWN FOR
YEARS. WE CANNOT A SYSTEM IN
STATE AND TO. ALL OF OUR
EFFORTS AND RESOURCES TO BETTER
SERVE OUR STUDENTS. AND IT'S
WORKING. WE'RE SHOWING WHAT IT
TAKES TO EDUCATE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF THEIR LIVES AND
THOSE OF THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES. WE CANNOT GO
BACKWARDS. WE MUST REMEMBER
THAT NONE OF THE ACTIONS THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN. OUR COST FREE.
THEY REQUIRED ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT FOR OUR CAMPUS FROM
THE STATE AND FROM THE CSU
SYSTEM. WE'VE DONE IT ON ONE
TIME FUNDING THAT WE WILL NOT
HAVE FOREVER WE'VE DONE ON
RESERVE BALANCES THAT WE WILL
NOT HAVE FOREVER WE CANNOT GO
BACKWARDS WE'VE CHANGED THE
CULTURE ON OUR CAMPUSES WOULD
CHANGE THE CULTURE OF OUR
STUDENTS. AND IF WE RETREAT
FROM THAT CHANGE IN CULTURE I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE RECOVER FROM
THAT. THE CLASSES WITH ADDED
OVER THAT LAST YEAR'S MUST
CONTINUE. THE SUMMER A MUST
CONTINUE. THE IMPROVE ADVISING
MODELS MUST GO ON. AS I SAID
EARLIER 80% OF OUR INCOMING
STUDENTS ARE PLEDGING TO TAKE A
FULL COURSE LOAD AND WE HAVE TO
BE THERE TO. OFFER THAT TO
THEM. THE PLAN FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ACADEMIC YEAR WE
NEED CONFIDENCE. THAT WILL HAVE
THAT FUNDING THERE TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE STUDENTS HAVE
WITHIN IT. REALLY APPRECIATE
THE TIME TO TALK WITH YOU
HAPPENING ATTORNEY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AT DR PER AS- I
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU WERE SO
EXCITED TO COME HERE AT THE
STORIES AND AT. THAT YOU HAVE
SHARED ARE INSPIRING AND-
REALLY CONFIDENT. BUILDING
BECAUSE- OF EACH SACRAMENTO
STATE UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP
UNDER PRESIDENT NELSON'S
LEADERSHIP HAVE REALLY BEEN ALL
STARS IN OUR STATE. AND SET
GREAT EXAMPLES FOR- WHERE THAT
COMMITMENT IN THAT LEADERSHIP
CAN PRODUCE HUGE RESULTS FOR
OUR STUDENTS HUGE. BECAUSE FOR
EVERY STUDENT A DROPS OUT IT'S
A TRAGEDY THAT'S RIGHT DEBT.
AND NO DEGREE AND- I CERTAINLY
WOULD'VE UNDERSCORE THE-
EXCITEMENT AT CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND HEARING
THOSE TROUBLING TO REALLY
TRIPLING OF NUMBERS AND FIVE
YEARS FOR. SO MANY DIFFERENT
CLASSES OF STUDENTS- IS JUST
VERY IMPRESSIVE AND THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR STORY MIGHT
HAVE SOME FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
AS WE- GO THROUGH THE OUT THE
AFTERNOON THANK YOU APPRECIATE.
YOUR JOINED BY ANOTHER CAMPUS
LEADER FROM SAN JOSE STATE.
THAT IS ALSO MADE GREAT
PROGRESS IN THAT THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM IN THE FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION- PROGRAM- DR
SALLY- HAD NOT NOTICE. AND WE
WELCOME YOU HERE WE THANK YOU
ON BEHALF OF YOUR INSTITUTION
FOR SHARING YOUR STORY. US
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER AND
SENATOR ALLEN. I THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THE REMARKABLE PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE MADE TOWARDS OUR
GOALS OF GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AT TEN OF
THE STATE AND IT'S REALLY
GRATIFYING FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO
HEAR FROM ONE OF MY SISTER
CAMPUSES AND SEE THAT WE ARE
SHARING A LOT OF ST THE SAME
PRACTICES AND SEEING THE SAME
OUTCOME SO THAT'S VERY
REINFORCING FOR ME. TO SEE THAT
IT'S WORKING EVERYWHERE.
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE HAS GIVEN US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CRITICALLY
EXAMINE. CURRICULUM ADVISING.
ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES. COURSE
SCHEDULING. AND ADMINISTRATIVE
ROAD BLOCKS WITH THE GOAL OF
SMOOTHING THE PATH FOR STUDENTS
TO EXCESS COULD SUCCEED. IN
THEIR MAJORS AND GRADUATE IN A
TIMELY FASHION. A WHEN WE BEGAN
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AS YOU
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER ARE FOR
YOUR GRADUATION RATE HAD
HARBORED STUBBORNLY NEAR ABOUT
10% FOR YEARS. BUT NOW WE'VE
RAISED THE FOUR YEAR GRADUATION
RATE TO TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
THIS TRANSLATES AT SAN JOSE
STATE TO FIVE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL FRESHMAN PER YEAR
COMPLETING THEIR DEGREE IN FOUR
YEARS. THE STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING WITH LESS DEBT WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME BENEFITING
FROM BEGINNING GRADUATESCHOOL
OR THEIR CRICKET. CAREER
TRAJECTORIES EARLIER. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT NO SINGLE
STRATEGY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPROVING THE STUDENT
EXPERIENCE AND RAISING
GRADUATION RATES. INSTEAD MANY
CHANGES BIG AND SMALL HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE FIFTEEN
PERCENTAGE POINT INCREASE.
ACTIONS A SMALLISH CHANGING A
DEADLINE. OR AS SIGNIFICANT AS
TRIPLING THE NUMBER OF ADVISERS
EACH RAISE THE GRADUATION AND
RETENTION RATES A LITTLE BIT.
EVERY DIVISION ON OUR CAMPUS IS
ENGAGED IN THIS EFFORT AND THE
STE AND STUDENT SUCCESS IS
EMBEDDED IN OUR TRANSFORMATION
TWENTY THIRTY STRATEGIC PLAN. I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME SPECIFIC STRATEGIES THAT
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO MORE THAN
DOUBLING OUR FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE IN JUST FOUR
YEARS. FIRST AND WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS IT A LOT BUT- IT'S
VERY VERY IMPORTANT WHICH IS
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS TAKING A FULL LOAD OF
FIFTEEN UNITS PER SEMESTER.
SECOND INCREASING THE RATIO OF
ADVISERS TO STUDENTS AND
DEVELOPING ROBUST ELECTRONIC
ADVISING TOOLS WHICH WAS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT SENATOR ROTH
WAS INTERESTED IN. AND THE
THIRD RETHINKING HOW WE DELIVER
CURRICULUM. ONE OF THE
BEHAVIORS THAT EXTENDS STUDENTS
TIME TO COMPLETION OF THEIR
DEGREES IS TAKING TOO FEW
UNITS. IF A STUDENT PLANS TO
COMPLETE A FOR A DEGREE IN FOUR
YEARS SHE MUST EARN THIRTY
UNITS PER YEAR. TYPICALLY THIS
IS DONE BY TAKING FIFTEEN UNITS
EACH SEMESTER BUT IN FALL
FIFTEEN. ONLY 19% OF OUR FIRST
TIME FRESHMEN TOOK A FULL LOAD
OF FIFTEEN UNITS. WE ARE
DELIGHTED TO REPORT THAT FOR
FALL TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT
PROPORTION HAS INCREASED TO
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT. A CLOSE TO
THREE FOLD INCREASE. A STUDENT
EARNING TWELVE UNITS EACH
SEMESTER IS UP IS FULL TIME.
FROM A FINANCIAL AID
PERSPECTIVE BUT IS ON A PATH TO
GRADUATE IN FIVE YEARS INSTEAD
OF FOR. THAT EXTRA YEAR ADDS
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
FEES AND LIVING EXPENSES NOT TO
MENTION THE OPPORTUNITY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH A DELAYED START
TO ONE'S CAREER. INCREASING
AVERAGE UNIT LOAD HAS BEEN A
MAJOR CULTURE SHIFT FOR
STUDENTS ADMINISTRATORS
ADVISORS AND FACULTY REQUIRING
CHANGES IN ATTITUDES AND
BELIEFS AS WELL AS POLICIES AND
PRACTICES THAT CREATE BARRIERS
AND I THINK YOU MENTIONED THE
SAME THING AT SACRAMENTO STATE.
WITH FUNDS FROM GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HIRE MORE
FACULTY TO OFFER MORE SECTIONS
AND THUS REDUCE WEIGHT LESS AND
BOTTLENECKS THAT PREVENT
STUDENTS FROM TAKING A FULL
FIFTEEN UNITS. LIKE OTHER
CAMPUSES IN THE CSU WE'VE
INITIATED A PHOENICIAN FOUR
CAMPAIGN FOR FRESHMAN AND IT
TAKE TO CAMPAIGN FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS ALONG WITH MESSAGING
TO STUDENTS AND THEIR PARENTS
ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF
COMPLETING THIRTY UNITS PER
YEAR. WE ARE MORE STRATEGIC
ABOUT THE COURSES WE OFFER IN
WINTER AND SUMMER SESSION BY
TARGETING COURSES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT PRE REQUISITES OR
THAT TEND TO HAVE UNMET DEMAND
DURING THE FALL AND SPRING
SEMESTERS. WE'VE DEVELOPED TWO
YEAR AND FOUR YEAR ROAD MAPS
FOR ALL UNDERGRADUATE DEGREES
AND PROGRAMS THEM INTO OUR
ELECTRONIC DEGREE PLANNER
CALLED MY PLANNER. STUDENTS AND
ADVISORS USE MY PLANNER TO
INSTANTANEOUSLY SEE THE IMPACT
OF OPTING TO EITHER TAKE OR
DELAYED TAKING A PARTICULAR
COURSE AT ANY POINT IN THEIR
PROGRAM. TO CREATE INCENTIVES
FOR STUDENTS TO COMPLETE THIRTY
UNITS PER YEAR SAN JOSE STATES
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM WAS
DESIGNED TO CAST A WIDE NET.
GIVING ANY CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
WHO WANTS TO MAKE THE PLEDGE
PERMISSION TO JOIN. CALIFORNIA
PROMISE STUDENTS ARE REQUIRED
TO ATTEND A WORKSHOP TO CREATE
A TWO OR FOUR YEAR PLANNER. A
PLAN IN MY PLANNER. AND BENEFIT
FROM EARLY REGISTRATION TO HELP
THEM TO GET THE CLASSES THEY
NEED AT THE TIMES THEY PREFER
AND I I'M NEED TO CLARIFY THE
TO YOUR PLAN IS FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND A FOR YOUR PLAN IS
FOR. SOMEONE WHO COMES AS A
FRESHMAN. WE CREATE WE RECRUIT
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
INTO THE PROGRAM AT SPARTAN
ADMIT DAY AND DURING OUR OUT
REACHED A HIGH SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALL OVER THE
STATE. AS OF SPRING TWENTY
TWENTY WE HAVE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM. ADVISERS
MONITOR STUDENT PROGRESS TO
ENSURE THEY SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETE. THIRTY UNITS PER
YEAR. IF THEY ARE NOT ON TRACK
TO COMPLETE THIRTY UNITS DURING
THE ACADEMIC YEAR WE ENCOURAGE
THEM TO TAKE SUMMER OR WINTER
CLASSES. IF STUDENTS DON'T MEET
THEIR PLEDGE AND THAT'S OR
DESCEND ROLE FROM THE PROGRAM
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO RE
ENTER AT A LATER TIME IF THEY
MEET ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
WE'VE INVESTED HEAVILY IN
ACADEMIC ADVISING. IN FALL
TWENTY FIFTEEN. THE UNIVERSITY
HAD ONE FULL TIME STAFF ADVISER
FOR EVERY EIGHTEEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY STUDENTS. WITH THE HELP
OF GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE FUNDING. WE HAVE
TRIPLED THE NUMBER OF ADVISERS
AND TODAY WE HAVE ONE ADVISER
FOR EVERY SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS.
WE HAVE A STUDENT SUCCESS
CENTER IN EACH OF OUR SEVEN
ACADEMIC COLLEGES THAT PROVIDES
A RANGE OF SERVICES INCLUDING
ACADEMIC ADVISING CAREER
ADVISING. STUDENT SUCCESS
WORKSHOPS AND TUTORING. WE HOLD
REGULAR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES FOR
ADVISORS AND HAVING ADVISING
COUNCIL THAT MEETS ON A REGULAR
BASIS TO DISCUSS ADVISING GOALS
STRATEGIES AND BEST PRACTICES
AS WELL AS OBSTACLES TO
DELIVERING HIGH QUALITY
ADVISING SERVICES. WE HAVE
BUILT AN ELECTRONIC ADVISING
TOOL CALLED MY PROGRESS THAT
STUDENTS CAN RUN ANY TIME OF
DAY OR NIGHT TO REVIEW WHICH
DEGREE REQUIREMENTS THEY'VE
COMPLETED. AND WHICH THEY STILL
NEED TO COMPLETE IF A STUDENT
THINKS A REQUIREMENT HAS BEEN
MET YET IT'S STILL SHOWING READ
IN MY PROGRESS THE STUDENT CAN
IMMEDIATELY BING THE
DISCREPANCY TO AN ADVISER.
TODAY TOGETHER THEY CAN
DETERMINE IF A TRANSCRIPT IS
MISSING OR THE STUDENT HAS AN
ALTERNATIVE COURSE WORK THAT
COULD BE SUBSTITUTED TO MEET
THAT REQUIREMENT. A REVIEW OF
MIKE PROGRESS EACH SEMESTER
ELIMINATE SURPRISES AT THE LAST
MINUTE THAT COULD DELAY
STUDENTS GRADUATION. ANOTHER
ELECTRONIC ADVISING TOOL
SPARTAN CONNECT ALLOWS FACULTY
AND ACADEMIC ADVISORS TO
IDENTIFY STUDENTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING AND CONNECT THEM
WITH THE SERVICES THEY NEED
SUCH AS TUTORING WORKSHOPS PEER
MENTORS AND COUNSELING SERVICES.
PERHAPS ONE OF THE MOST
INSPIRING PROJECTS HAS BEEN THE
REVISION OF OUR CURRICULUM TO
REPLACE NON CREDIT BEARING
REMEDIAL MATH AND WRITTEN
COMMUNICATION COURSE WORK WAS
SUPPORTED INSTRUCTION AND I
THINK THIS WAS ONE OF YOUR-
BABIES. AND IT'S BEEN
REMARKABLE WHAT'S GOING ON.
THIS PROJECT WAS INITIATED IN
AUGUST. TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN
RESPONSE TO EXECUTIVE ORDER
ELEVEN TEN FROM THE CSU
CHANCELLOR. WITH FUNDS FROM
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE SAN JOSE STATE
FACULTY HAVE DEVELOPED CO
REQUISITE WORKSHOPS AND STRETCH
COURSES. TO ASSIST STUDENTS AND
THEIR COLLEGE LEVEL MATH AND
WRITING. A STRETCH COURSE
EXTENDS THE CONTENT OVER TWO
SEMESTERS TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
MORE TIME TO MASTER THE
MATERIAL. FACULTY HAVE
DEVELOPED NEW COURSES SUCH AS
MATHEMATICS IN ART AND MUSIC
AND MATHEMATICS AND POLITICS
ONE THAT I THINK YOU WOULD
PROBABLY ENJOY TAKING. A TO
PROVIDE EXCITING ALTERNATIVES
TO BASIC ALGEBRA. WEATHER IS
STUDENTS PURSUING A CALCULUS
BASED OR STATISTICS BASED
DEGREE PROGRAM OR PROGRAM IN
WHICH GENERAL EDUCATION MATH IS
THE ONLY QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENT WE HAVE CREATED
SUPPORT PAT SUPPORTED PATHWAYS
THAT ALIGN WITH THE LEVEL OF
EACH STUDENT'S PREPARATION WHEN
THEY ARRIVE AT SAN JOSE STATE.
A STUDENT WHO'S HIGH SCHOOL
PREPARATION INDICATE SHE'S
READY FOR COLLEGE LEVEL MATH
MIGHT JUMP RIGHT INTO
STATISTICS ANOTHER STUDENT
WHOSE PREPARATION INDICATE
SUPPORT IS NEEDED WOULD TAKE
THE STRETCH VERSION OF
STATISTICS. SIMILARLY STUDENTS
CAN TAKE A ONE SEMESTER ENGLISH
ONE A COURSE OR A STRETCH
VERSION IF THEY FEEL THEY NEED
MORE READING AND WRITING
SUPPORT. IN THE WRITING ARENA
WE'VE USED GRADUATION TWENTY
ADDITION OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
FUNDS TO PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR FACULTY TO
INTEGRATE READING
APPRENTICESHIP TEACHING
FRAMEWORKS INTO OUR ENGLISH ONE
EIGHT COURSES. READING
APPRENTICESHIP IS A RESEARCH
BASED ODEL THAT HELP STUDENTS
LEARN HOW TO MONITOR THEIR
COMPREHENSION AND HOW TO
RESTORE IT WHEN IT BREAKS DOWN.
READING COMPREHENSION IS
ESSENTIAL TO SUCCESS IN
UNDERSTANDING COLLEGE LEVEL
TEXT. GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE HAS ALLOWED
US TO HIRE PEER EDUCATORS AS
TUTORS AND AS MENTORS IN THE
FIRST YEAR MATH AND WRITING
COURSES. THESE MENTORS MENTORS
GO BEYOND TUTORING CONTENT THEY
HELP STUDENTS WITH COLLEGE
SUCCESS SKILLS SUCH AS- STUDY
STRATEGIES TIME MANAGEMENT AND
ENGAGEMENT WITH CAMPUS
RESOURCES AND ACTIVITIES. I'M
REALLY EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO
TELL YOU THE RESULTS OF THIS
INTENSIVE WORK. OUR GOAL IS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE THEIR
GENERAL EDUCATION WRITTEN AND
MATHEMATICS REQUIREMENTS IN
THEIR FIRST YEAR AT SAN JOSE
STATE. MATH AND WRITING ARE
FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS THAT
SUPPORT STUDENT SUCCESS IN
SUBSEQUENT COURSES. OF THE
FRESHMEN WHO ENTERED IN FALL
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ONE YEAR
AGO. 91% COMPLETED THEIR G. G.
E. WRITTEN A COMMUNICATION
REQUIREMENT IN THEIR FIRST YEAR
THE YEAR BEFORE THAT TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ONLY 72% ARE
COMPLETED THEIR WRITTEN RICK
COMMUNICATION REQUIREMENTS A
YEAR TO YEAR GAIN OF NINETEEN
PERCENTAGE POINTS. IN MATH THE
NEWS IS EVEN MORE COMPELLING.
82% OF FRESHMEN WHO ENTERED IN
FALL TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
COMPLETED THEIR G. E.
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENT COMPARED TO ONLY
54% OF FRESHMEN WHO ENTERED AND
FALL SEVENTEEN A YEAR TO YEAR
GAIN OF TWENTY EIGHT PERCENTAGE
POINTS. THESE STUDENTS OF
MASTER KEY SKILLS THAT THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO APPLY TO THEIR
COURSE WORK AS THEY COMPLETE
THEIR DEGREES IN CLOSING WE ARE
PROUD OF THE PROGRESS WE'VE
MADE A TENNESSEE STATE WITH
CONTINUED GRADUATION
INITIATIVE. TO OF TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE SUPPORT WE ARE CONFIDENT
THAT WE CAN MEET OUR GRADUATION
RATE GOALS FOR FRESHMEN AND
TRANSFER STUDENTS OF COURSE WE
STILL HAVE WORK TO DO. THIS
YEAR WE ARE FOCUSING OUR
ATTENTION ON STRATEGIES TO
REDUCE EQUITY GAPS AND INCREASE
FIRST YEAR RETENTION RATES THE
DATA SHOW THAT ONE STUDENTS
COMPLETE THEIR FIRST TWO YEARS
THERE IS A 90% CHANCE THAT THEY
WILL COMPLETE THEIR DEGREES
WHILE ALL OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
SUCCEEDING AT HIGHER RATES. THE
EQUITY GAPS ARE STUBBORN AND WE
NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE THE GAPS.
IN YOUR PACKET WE- PROVIDED YOU
A PLAN THAT SUMMARIZES OUR
STRATEGIES FOR THIS YEAR TO
CONTINUE OUR POSITIVE MOMENTUM
IN ADDRESSING OUR STUDENT NEEDS
AND CREATING AN AND COLLUSIVE
AND WELCOMING EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT SAN JOSE STATE SO
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SHARE
OUR STORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
A DOCTOR DIAGNOSE- AND
CERTAINLY OUR THANKS TO
PRESIDENT OF THE PAYS IAN AND
TO YOUR FACULTY YOU KNOW THESE
THINGS ARE EASY AND- IT
CERTAINLY- AT THE FOR THE
PROGRESS WITH FOR FRESHMAN UNIT
LOAD AND WHAT YOU'VE DONE WITH
ADVISING. AND YEAH THERE'S SO
MANY THERE'S SO MANY THINGS AND
YOU SAID AT THE BEGINNING YOUR
TESTIMONY THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS LITTLE THINGS THAT SOME
HELP TOGETHER TURN INTO BIG
THINGS AND- AND IT TAKES A LOT
OF WORK AND IT MAY IT GOT OF. A
FEW PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR COMFORT
ZONE I KNOW SENATOR ALLEN AND
I- HAD A HEARING ON THE WHOLE
CHANGE IN REMEDIATION- AND
THERE WAS A LOT OF RESISTANCE
TO THAT AND DID REQUIRE A LOT
OF WORK FROM. THE FACT TO
REDUCE. CORE BUT I THINK IT WAS
A- A FOR SITE OUT FAR SIGHTED
AND- WE IN ESSENCE A BRILLIANT.
PLAN THAT THE CHANCE SO WHY A
DOCTOR MINOR. THAT YOU ALL
ADVANCED AND I KNOW HOW HARD IT
WAS BUT I THINK YOU WERE SEEN
IN THE PROGRESS- WHERE
STUDENTS. ARE TAKING COURSES
THAT. CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR
GRADUATION NOT CREATE A
SITUATION LIKE YOURS STALLED.
AND YOU'RE NOT REALLY AND THAT
IN THE COLLEGE ELAINE YET AND
THE THINGS THAT- NEGATIVELY
AFFECT THEIR COMMITMENT TO.
ADVANCING TOWARDS THEIR DEGREES
SO- MATHEMATICS IN POLITICS WE
COULD USE THAT AROUND HERE BY
THE WAY. I'D LIKE TO GO TAKE
THAT COURSE MAYBE WE'RE ALREADY
TAKEN IT I'M NOT SURE- WELL I
WANT TO AT. I WANT HAD SOME
QUESTIONS FOR DOCTOR MINOR AND-
I. YEAH WE'RE CELEBRATING THESE
TWO CAMPUS SUCCESSES AND IN THE
MATERIALS THAT HAVE BEEN
PREPARED BY STAFF AND I
CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK STOCKS
YOU ALL YET FROM MY TEAM WHO
PUT THIS. TOGETHER BUT THERE IS
A CHART HERE IN RED. WHICH THAT
SHOWS THAT THE DISSIPATION BY
CAMPUS IN THE CALIFORNIA
PROBLEMS PROGRAM. ALEC
KNOWLEDGE AGAIN THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS THAT GO INTO THE
SUCCESSES THAT WE'VE HAD. AND
THE CAL PROMISE PROGRAM WHERE
IT'S STUDENTS COMMIT TO TAKING
THE UNIT COUNT THAT WE PROVIDE
REGISTRATION PRIORITY ADVISING.
THAT'S JUST A THAT'S A PIECE
THAT'S JUST A PIECE OF FIVE
WHERE WE CAN POTENTIALLY SEE
PROGRESS AND WE LOOK AT THIS
CHART YOU CAN SEE- THAT WHILE
THE MANY CAMPUSES OF COMMITTED
TO THE PROGRAM- ONLY IF YOU
HAVE REALLY COMMITTED
WHOLEHEARTEDLY TO IT AND TWO OF
THEM ARE HERE SAN JOSE STATE.
SACRAMENTO STATE LONG BEACH
STATE WHERE WE SEE SOME REALLY
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS- IN
ENROLLING IN THE PROMISE
PROGRAM AND YET FOR SO MANY OF
THE OTHER CAMPUSES- IT THE BUT
SUFFICIENT RATE IS BEEN VERY
LOW AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CAMPUS IS THAT IT. HAD DONE SO
POORLY IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS-
EAST BAY CAL STATE EAST BAY-
YOU KNOW HOW MANY STUDENTS ARE
IN THIS PROGRAM SIXTY- WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THAT. FRESNO ONLY A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE STUDENTS
THIS YEAR IN A MID SIZE CAMPUS
SIMILAR TO SACRAMENTO STATE
ONLY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE.
COMPARE THAT TO SACRAMENTO
STATE WITH WHAT TWENTY HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO. THEIR PROMISE
PROGRAM IT'S A MASSIVE THAT'S A
MASSIVE DIFFERENCE. SO DOCTOR
MINOR CAN YOU SPEAK TO I WOULD
NOW CELEBRATED THE SUCCESSES
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THE TOOLS
THAT HAVE ALLOWED IT TO HAPPEN
AND HOW WE HAVE TO KEEP IT
GOING. IN REGARD TO OUR BUDGET-
AS EVER AT AND OTHER THINGS
BUT- CAN YOU SPEAK TO I KNOW
THE COMMITMENT IN LEGISLATION
WEST WAS AT SEVEN. FOR YOU KNOW
FOR FRESHMAN PROGRAMS AND
YOU'VE DONE MORE BUT YET WE'RE
NOT SEEING THAT THE DISSIPATION
RATE AND SO MANY FIFTY TWO
COULD YOU SPEAK TO THAT. YEAH
THANK YOU SENATOR I AYE A WILL
AND AS YOU ALL THIS IS A
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE BEEN
HAVING SYSTEM WIDE. THERE THERE
ARE FEW. VERY ASKING. ARE
WORTHY OF SO DESCRIBE NOW
CERTAINLY A- MY- TO. THAT SIX.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE TODAY THAT IS
BRANDING I THINK MANY OF OUR
CAMPUSES HAD A WAR OR EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
SIMILAR SERVE SIMILAR
FUNCTIONS. PRIOR TO THE
LEGISLATION AND YOUR NOW
STARTING TO SEE SOME CAMPUSES
MERCH PROGRAMS THAT MAY HAVE
BEEN BRANDED DIFFERENTLY
FIFTEEN TO FINISH. ALL THE
WORSE CALIFORNIA PROMISE. LIKE
BUT NOT BRANDED AS SUCH AND SO
WEST CAMPUSES ARE. COUNTING THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROGRAM
OR THAT PROGRAM STUDENTS WHO
MAY BE. EXPERIENCING THE
BENEFITS OF A SIMILAR PROGRAM.
MAY NOT BE REGISTERED OR ROLLED
SO THAT THAT'S ONE ELEMENT THAT
I THINK. IS WORTHY OF
DISCUSSION THE OTHER IS SOME
VARIATION AND CRITERIA. WHAT
WE'RE LEARNING FROM OUR
CAMPUSES THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO WHEN PRESENTED WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY- STEVE MENTIONED
THE CULTURE CHANGES THAT ARE
HAPPENING. NOT ONLY WITH THE
FACULTY AND STAFF BUT ALSO WITH
OUR STUDENTS IN TERMS OF WHAT
KIND OF EXPECTATIONS- WE HAVE
FOR THEM UPON ARRIVAL IS
INTERESTING I THINK. ROUGHLY
84% OF OUR STUDENTS. WHEN YOU
ASK THEM HOW MANY EXPECT TO
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS ABOUT
84% OF THE HANDS GO UP. IF YOU
SAT AND SPOKE WITH THOSE
STUDENTS ABOUT WHAT'S
TECHNICALLY NECESSARY IN ORDER
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN MANY OF- ARE
SORT OF ON AWARE AND THAT
DOESN'T EVEN ACCOUNT FOR. NOT
BEING ABLE TO GET A COURSE IN A
pIT- OR THE EXPECTATION THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ENROLLED IN
MAKING SUCH A WHAT BUT MAY SEEM
LIKE A SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT
IN THEIR FIRST YEAR. SO THERE'S
JUST SOME- ENGAGEMENT THAT WE
HAVE TO DO AND WITH RESPECT TO
ADVISE AND IN A ROW TO STUDENTS
IN THE PROGRAM. THE OTHER
VARIABLE I WILL MENTION IS THE
ABILITY OF STUDENTS WHO MAKE
THE PLAY AT AGE. IN YEAR ONE OR
TERM ONE. ROOM ON TRACK. AND
THREE SEMESTER FOR SEMESTER
FIVE. SO IN ANY GIVEN TERM
WE'RE WE'RE COUNTY HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE PARTICIPATING.
THERE IS SOME ATTRITION THAT WE
HAVE TO ACCOUNT FOR- THE FINAL
THING THAT I WILL MENTION AND I
DON'T KNOW THAT THIS REPRESENTS
AN ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM. IS
THAT THE INSTITUTIONAL
COMMITMENT TO FOR FIELD A
PROMISE AND I AND I KNOW THAT
THAT IS A DELICATE AND
SENSITIVE ISSUE. BUT IT IS-
VARIABLE AND IN TERMS OF HOW
YOU SEE SOME VARIATION IN AND
HOW STUDENTS ARE PARTICIPATING.
AND I THINK I'D LIKE TO DRAFT
ON THAT LAST POINT BECAUSE I
RECOGNIZE. THAT THAT REALLY.
THAT YEAH THERE'S A COMMITMENT
ON- ON THE STUDENT'S PART WHEN
THEY SAY I WANT TO GET OUT IN
FOUR YEARS. AND I'M COMMITTING
TO TRY TO TAKE THE UNIT COUNT
TO GET OUT AND THAT'S A
COMMITMENT. AND THE INSTITUTION
SAYING OKAY WE'RE GONNA GET YOU
MAKE SURE YOU'RE GONNA GET THE
CLASSES YOU NEED AND YOU GET
THE ADVISED. NEED I UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT. STRONG INSTITUTION
TO BE ABLE TO THAT COMMITMENT-
AB BUT THAT BUT YET THAT'S THAT
WHAT. THAT'S WHAT WE NEED OUR
CAMPUSES TO REALLY DO RIGHT AND
IF THERE ARE ROADBLOCKS TO
DOING THAT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE ARE I
FIND INTERESTING- THE YOU KNOW
THE COAL HEART STRATEGY WHERE
ARE YOU WERE ALREADY SELECTING
PRE SELECTING COURSES IF YOU
SAY YOU WANT TO BE A MATH MAJOR
OR HISTORY MAJOR. THE
INSTITUTIONS IT'S SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO DO IN A COLLECTION OF
KIDS THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
SAME GOALS THAT HAVE AND WE'RE
GONNA OUT IDENTIFIES COURSES
THEY KEEP TRACK I THINK THAT'S
A BIG MODEL AN EXAMPLE. OF
WHERE I'VE GOT TO COME A POINT
OF VIEW OF MAKING SURE THE
CLASSES ARE AVAILABLE BUT THAT
THAT THAT INSTITUTIONAL HUG
ABOUT WE'RE GOING TO BE WITH
YOU AND- ALONE- IS A VERY
IMPRESSIVE- PATHWAY THAT I
THINK I BUT IT SURE. AS WELL.
BUT THE PRESSURE ON INSTITUTION
TO MAKE THOSE CLASSES AVAILABLE
IS A BIG DEAL AND I AM NOT WHEN
I TALK TO STUDENTS- AND WE'VE
BEEN ON A WHOLE BUNCH OF
CAMPUSES IN THE LAST YEAR. DATE
THEY'VE UNIVERSALLY TALK ABOUT
THE AVAILABILITY CLASS I CAN
GET MY CLASSES AND I KNOW
SOMETIMES AND STUDENTS SAY THAT
THEY JUST DON'T WANT TO GET UP
EARLY AND I WANT TO GET ON THAT
EIGHT AM CLASS I KNOW I
REMEMBER. I REMEMBER I DID TAKE
A FEW EIGHT AM CLASSES AND
ABOUT SENATOR ALLEN HE SEES THE
RIVER GET UP KIND OF LATE BUT
SEVEN TWENTY. YOU TOOK A SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT YEAH. YEAH YOU HAD
NO CHOICE ON A HIGH SCHOOL
COURSE. BUT A SUB- AYE AYE BUT
WE NEED YOU KNOW. WHAT LOOK
LOOK AT THAT IT LOOK AT
EASTBAY. AT A SITUATION WHERE
THEY'VE ACTUALLY GONE BACKWARDS
IN FIVE YEARS. AND THEY DON'T
SEEM TO BE PROVIDING THE
PATHWAY AT LEAST THROUGH THE
PROMISE PROGRAM MAYBE THERE'S
ALTERNATIVES THAT THEY PROVIDED
ON THEIR CAMPUSES BUT THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE HARDER NUMBERS TO
KIND OF UNDERSTAND- AND WE'RE
WE'RE IN THE PROBLEM SOLVING
MODE WE WANT TO HELP EVERY
STUDENT EVERY CAMPUS IT'S ALSO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE IN THE
STATE- WE WANT TO HELP YOU WE
WOULD HAVE A MISSION. BUT
SOMEBODY THIS IS THE WILL
DURING TO NOT UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY- YOU KNOW IT WHILE THE E.
YOU'RE GIVING THEM SOME FREEDOM
TO DO THINGS THEIR OWN WAY AND
I APPRECIATE THAT. BUT BUT IT'S
NOT HAPPENING AND- EAT IN SOME
OF THESE CAMPUSES I THINK I
TOLD YOU THE STORY- PUP MONA.
WE SAT DOWN WITH THE STUDENTS
AT POMONA. I ASKED HOW MANY OF
THEM WERE AWARE OF A FOUR YEAR
TRACK CALLED THE PROMISE
PROGRAM CALLED FINISHING FOR
WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL IT. OF
THOSE TWENTY FIVE STUDENT
COUNCIL MEMBERS AROUND THAT IN
THE ROOM. NOT A SINGLE PERSON
IS THERE HAVE A THEY WERE EVEN
A WHAT ARE. ABOUT FOUR YEAR
PATHWAY THAT THEY COULD GET ON
ON THAT CAMPUS. AND THAT'S NOT
TO SAY THINGS ARE GOING PRETTY
WELL AT THE MOMENT THEY ARE
THERE SOME REAL PROGRESS POINTS
MONA SO I DON'T WANT TO. THROW
THEM UNDER THE BUS. BUT WE GO
TO THE MINGUS HILLS SAME THING-
AND SO THIS ISSUE OF AWARENESS
IS A BIG DEAL YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE WEBSITE YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE COMMITMENT FROM THE CHASER
WHICH WE APPRECIATE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE AWAY. AT LEAST
WITH. YOU KNOW SIGN IN PLACE IS
A LITTLE BIT MORE PROMINENT
BUT- WHAT CAN THE SYSTEM DO I
KNOW YOU WRITE YOU WITH. YOU
RECOGNIZE THE ECONOMY THE
CAMPUSES YOU'RE THERE TO BE
THERE. THERE IS YOUR IS THERE
ASSISTANCE AND- BIRD THEIR
GUIDANCE COUNSELOR PERSON IF
YOU IF YOU WILL. BUT WHAT CAN
WE DO MORE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WHILE THAT MAY FEEL THE
PRESSURE OF WE GOT TO MAKE THE
CLASSES AVAILABLE OF PEOPLE
SIGN UP FOR THE FOR YOUR TRACK.
THAT'S THEY NEED TO DO. REALLY
IS WHAT THEY NEED TO. ALSO
PETER IT'S A IT'S A GREAT. WHAT
THOSE ARE GREAT EXAND I WILL
BE THE FIRST TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS SYSTEMATICALLY PROVIDING
CRITICAL INFORMATION TO
INCOMING STUDENTS IS A
CHALLENGE AYE AYE I SAT DOWN
WITH THE- A GROUP OF STUDENTS
FOR DINNER- IT WHEN I WAS
VISITING THE CAMPUS A FEW WEEKS
AGO. AND ONE OF THE STUDENTS
SAID TO ME HE- I THANK GOD I
WAS ASKING ABOUT WERE IN TATIAN
STUDENTS SAID TO ME WELL I
DIDN'T GO TO ORIENTATION WHAT
DO YOU MEETING GOING I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT IT. SO IN MY MIND
HOW DOES THE INCOMING STUDENTS
NOT GET GOOD INFORMATION ABOUT
SOMETHING AS CRITICAL AS
ADVISING SO I KNOW THAT THAT
HAPPENS NOT JUST PUT THIS
PROGRAM THAT'S WHAT. OTHER
AREAS WHERE STUDENTS ARE NOT
RECEIVING CRITICAL INFORMATION.
JUST ONE BIT FURTHER ON THIS.
IS THAT A STUDENT SUCCESS
SUMMIT ON ONE OF THE CAMPUSES
AND THERE WAS THIS HUGE DEBATE
ABOUT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
EMAIL. AND THERE WAS A SORT OF
ONGOING JOKE ABOUT THE
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS ACTUALLY
READ EMAILS THAT COME FROM. THE
INSTITUTION SO THERE WAS A REAL
ALL CONVERSATION ABOUT
ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF
TRANSMITTING CRITICAL IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TO STUDENTS. SO I
THINK YOU KNOW THAT IS A BIG
PART OF OUR STRATEGY YOU HEARD
ME MENTION EARLIER. THAT THIS
WILL NOW BECOME A FEATURE ON
CAL STATE APPLY. I SAW THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
APPLICANTS EACH YEAR THAT ARE
GOING TO THAT WEBSITE- THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE WILL BE
FEATURED THERE AND A TAB WITH
INFORMATION AND AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEM.TO FIND ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON THEIR CAMPUS AND
I THINK THAT WILL GO A LONG
WAY. ARE THE OTHER IS THAT I
THINK YOU CONTINUING TO PUSH US
ON THIS ISSUE. HAS FOR SOME
ACTION AS I MENTIONED THE
CHANCELLOR'S NOW COMMUNICATING
WITH CAMPUS PRESIDENT. THERE
ARE A HANDFUL OF OTHER KERN
COMMUNICATIONS THAT HAVE GONE
TO OUR CAMPUS LEADERS ABOUT HOW
TO MORE PROMINENTLY FEATURED
THIS PROGRAM SO. ARE WE HAVE
MADE A COMMITMENT TO THIS AND I
EXPECT THAT YOU WILL SEE
IMPROVEMENTS ACROSS THE BOARD
WE GOT FOR. I STORY IN A LOT
ANGELES TIMES A FEW DAYS AGO
TOP. THE CAST LA WAS DOING WITH
PARENTS BRING THEM AT THE RIGHT
TIME THE SEMESTER. IN THERE I
BELIEVE IT WAS THEIR FRESHMAN
YEAR TO MAKE SURE THAT- THEY
KNEW- WHAT WAS GOING ON SO THEY
COULD CONNECT BETTER WITH THEIR
STUDENTS AND TO MONITOR AND I
THOUGHT THAT WAS A REALLY
POSITIVE THING TO DO YOU KNOW
AGAIN ANOTHER EXAMPLE. CAL LOS
ANGELES IS THE LOWEST
GRADUATION RATES IN THE STATE
AND THEY ARE NOT ONE OF THE FEW
CAMPUSES THAT ARE NOT
PARTICIPATING IN EITHER THE TWO
YEAR. OR THE FORTY PLEDGE
PROGRAM AND I APPRECIATED THAT
STILL THEIR CHOICE BUT IT'S
OKAY IF IT'S CHOI IF THEY'RE
MAKING PROGRESS. BUT IF NOT
MAKING PROGRESS A SERIOUS
MATTER THAT'S THAT'S NOT JUST
THEIR FAILURE THAT'S OUR
FAILURE TO AND I THINK WE ALL
FEEL THAT. WE ARE YOUR PARTNERS
AND- I WAS GLAD THAT SENATOR
ROTTEN CENTER LABOR WERE HERE
EARLIER BECAUSE- THEY SAID ON
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AND
THEY'VE HEARD FROM ME AND THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM ME.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
INVESTING IN OUR- FOUR YEAR.
GRADUATE PROGRAM OUR STUDENT
SUCCESS PROGRAM THAT. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE GOVERNOR-
YOU KNOW DESERVES A LOT OF
PRAISES BUDGET LAST YEAR WAS.
ONE OF THE MOST GENEROUS FOR
THE CSU THAT WE'VE HAD IN A
LONG TIME AND- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED IN JANUARY- REALLY HAS
SOME SHORTCOMINGS TO IT. IT'S
MY HOPE THAT WITH UNDER CENTER
RAS. LEADERSHIP THE CENTER
LEYVA SENATOR ALLEN. THAT WE
CAN- AGAIN DO WHAT WE HAVE IN
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS IS
IDENTIFY THESE ELEMENTS FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS. WHETHER IT'S
AN ACADEMIC ADVISING OR IF IT'S
IN COUNSELING- WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT BASIC NEEDS ANOTHER
HEARINGS WE YOU YOU OFFER A
STATE AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT
BEFORE. I DON'T WANT TO LOSE
SIGHT OF I'M- OF. SHELL AND-
FOOD AND OTHER ELEMENTS THAT
GET IT INTO THE TO CLASS AND-
MOTIVATED TO DO WELL. BUT I'M
GONNA CONTINUE TO PUT FOR THE
RESOURCE. HEY I CAN'T I AS A
SAID AT THE START OF THE
HEARING T. TAKE TAKE TO PROVIDE
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT LESS THAN 1%
IMPROVEMENT IN THE C. AS HIS
BUDGET AND GET A FORTY SEVEN
PERCENT- IMPROVEMENT AND
OUTCOME. THERE'S NOT A PROGRAM
IN STATE GOVERNMENT THAT IS HAD
THAT SUCCESS. THERE THERE
ISN'T. WE HEAR A LOT OF TALK-
WE'VE BOTH THE SAT ON BUDGET
COMMITTEES IN THE PAST WHERE
PEOPLE SAID IF YOU GIVE US SOME
MORE MONEY. WE CAN DO BETTER
WHATEVER IT IS AND WE DO A LOT
OF GREAT HINGS IN STATE
GOVERNMENT- AND THAT'S ALWAYS
THE ARGUMENT. IT'S A GOOD
INVESTMENT. AND I THINK THE
FACTS THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US A
CLEAR THIS IS NOT JUST TALK.
THIS IS A REAL. REAL SHE-
MOVING WHAT YOU SAY YOU. DO
MOVING- AND THE RETURN TO THE-
MESS AND I PLEDGE TO YOU MY
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO TRY TO-
INCREASE THE SUPPORT FOR THE
PROGRAMS IN WHICH OF COMMENTS
AND SPOKEN ABOUT TODAY- BEFORE
I GO TO POWER PUBLIC HEARING
PORTION CENTER ALLEN ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE BEFORE YEAH
WELL THANK YOU FOR- JUSTIFICA
QUESTIONS FIRST OF ALL I. I YOU
NEED TO WE HAVE THE FIVE YEAR
RATES. WE HAVE HEARD THE
EQUIVALENT CHART FOR FIVE YEAR
RAISES OPPOSED TO FOUR YEAR.
FOR THIS. YEAH THAT SIX ZERO
EIGHT YEAH ON THE NIGHT ARE
ONLY FOR YOUR RIGHTS NOT THE
SIX YEAR RATES SIX YOUR
GRADUATION RATES YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT FOUR OR FIVE. YEAR WELL
WE HAVE THERE IS THE OVERALL
PROGRESS SO FIVE YEARS AGO THE
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE WAS
NINETEEN PERCENT. AND NOW TO
TWENTY EIGHT. SO THAT THAT'S
THE ONLY. I GUESS I'M I'M
ASKING ABOUT A FIVE YEAR
GRADUATION RATE. WITH WITH
PERCENT HOW HOW MUCH- HOW MANY
WHAT ACTUALLY GRADUATED FIVE
YES FIVE YEAH. DOCTOR MINOR MAY
HAVE SOME INSIGHT I AM NOT
REMEMBERING THE PERCENTAGE OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD BUT IT IS-
SOUL. IF IT'S POSSIBLE WE WILL
PROMISE ALL RIGHT THAT TO YOU
RIGHT AWAY. AND THOSE NUMBERS
HAVE GONE UP AS WELL. RIGHT
WELL WE THINK YEAH YEAH. I'M I
WANTED EASY THANK EVERY FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT GOES BEHIND THIS
DATA BOTH YOU KNOW. THE
LEGISLATORS WHO PUSHED AND THAT.
THE MINISTERS WHO HELPED TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN I GUESS I'M. I
LISTEN TO ALL THE THINGS THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE DONE THE THINGS
YOU'VE IMPLEMENTED TO HELP MAKE
THESE. THESE DATA COME TO LIFE
I SUPPOSE MY QUESTION FOR YOU
IS. YOUR THEY WERE DEVOTED GOOD
PEOPLE WORKING IN THE SYSTEM IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN SOME OF YOU
YOURSELVES OR IN SYSTEM AT THE
TIME WHY WASN'T. WHOA WHAT WAS
WHAT WAS THE DIFFERENCE I MEAN
I UNDERSTAND I DON'T  DON'T
NEED AT THE END I'M NOT ASKING
FOR YOU TO KIND OF REPEAT ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'VE DONE
AND- TO GET TO WHERE WE ARE
BUT- BUT WHAT WAS THE- THERE
WAS JUST AS MUCH OF AN
IMPERATIVE AND IS THERE IS NOW.
WHAT WAS STOPPING THE SYSTEM
FROM IMPLEMENTING THOSE KINDS
OF. THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS
BEFORE. I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR
OUR CAMPUSES I'M I'M I'VE ONLY
BEEN ON OUR CAMPUS IN OUR
SYSTEM PROUD OF WHAT ALL OF OUR
OUR CAMPUS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO
THE DIFFERENCE WAS A CONSCIOUS
AND STARK CHANGE AND CULTURE
AND THE WAY WE AND OUR
COMMITMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS HAVE WHAT THEY
NEED- THERE WAS A THERE WAS A
MEETING WE CALLED- I WAS VICE
PROVOST OF THE TIME- WE CALLED
IT SEVEN O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING. BEFORE YOU PUT A STOP
SCHOOL WOULD ALLOW THE DEANS
THE SAYS DEANS AND SAID- MAKE
SURE YOU ADD SECTIONS WHEN OUR
STUDENTS NEED THEM- AND THIS IS
A DRAMATIC CHANGE AND BUT AS I
SAID WE CHANGE WE OPTED ABOUT
IT SO THAT OUR COLLEGES AVE NO
REASON NOT TO ADD CLASSES
BECAUSE WE'RE PAYING FOR THEM
CENTRAL OUT OF ACADEMIC
AFFAIRS. AND SO THEY COULDN'T
COULDN'T HAVE THAT TRADE OFF OF
I DON'T OFFER THIS SECTION I
CAN USE THE MONEY FOR SOMETHING
ELSE THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
WE HAVE CHANGED THE WAY WE LOOK
AT THINGS BUT WE ABOUT THINGS
SOME OF WHAT. OUR FOR CULTURE.
THE RESULT IS GREAT. WE HAD SO.
FUNDING CUTS IN PEOPLE'S OF.
RETREATED A SHELL AND IT TOOK.
A DISRUPTION. TO BREAK US OUT
OF THAT SHOW- AND ALLOW PEOPLE
TO. TO DO IT EVERYBODY CAME TO
THIS UNIVERSITY TO DO WHICH IS
TO HELP OUR STUDENTS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL NOW WE- NOW WE HAVE
THE FREEDOM TO GO AHEAD AND DO
THAT- BECAUSE THIS SUMMER
MONEY. BECAUSE IT WELL IT WOULD
BECAUSE WE'VE DEVOTED MONEY-
WE'VE GOT WE'VE RECEIVED MORE
MONEY- OTHER DIVISIONS WITHIN
THE UNIVERSITY HAVE EITHER
TAKEN CUTS ARE TAKEN SMALLER
INCREASES- COMPARED ACADEMIC
AFFAIRS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN- SUSTAIN. THE INSTITUTIONAL
INSTRUCTION CAPACITY THAT WE'VE
HAD WE'VE RECEIVED- MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A ONE
TIME MONEY. FROM THE UNIVERSITYOUT OF PRESERVES TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE- THAT
PROGRESS AND SO IT WAS A
CONSCIOUS. TO DO IT DIFFERENTLY
AND THEN THE ENHANCE IT JUST
SLIGHTLY MORE- AT BECAUSE I HAD
A FRONT ROW SEAT TO THIS THAT-
WHEN. WE WERE AS A TRUSTEE AT
THE TIME. WHEN WE WERE- HIRING
AND USE THE UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENT I CHAIR THAT
COMMITTEE SACRAMENTO STATE. AND
WAS CLEAR THAT 8% FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE WAS NO GOOD AND
THAT WE'RE GONNA GET NEW
LEADERSHIP ON THE CAMPUS. WE
NEED LEADERSHIP THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED- TO DOING BETTER AND SO
WHEN PRESIDENT NELSON WAS
HIRED. HE KNEW THE FIVE
TRUSTEES AT. THAT THIS. AND I
THINK IF HE WAS HERE AND HE HAS
TESTIFIED IN THE PAST TO
EXPLAIN THAT. THAT HE'S MADE
SOME BUDGET DECISIONS THAT
DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF
BACKSTOPS. WHEN YOU USE
RESERVES- EITHER YOU CAN'T GO
AND SAY THEY'RE GOING TO
REAPPEAR. IN THE NEXT YEAR. AND
HE HAS MADE OTHER CHOICES OF
REDUCING IN PLACES THAT CAN BE
UNPOPULAR. ON CAMPUS BUT HE HAS
OF THE EMBRACE THIS CULTURE
CHANGE THAT YOU HAVE REFLECTED
IN YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
SENATOR ALLEN A FIVE IF I MAY I
WANT TO JUST GIVE YOU A SYSTEM
VIEW OF WHAT. SORT OF WHAT
HAPPENED HERE. I THINK IN PART
IN LARGE PART THIS IS AN
EXTENSION OF WHAT. IN THIS
HAPPENING NOW ACTUALLY IN IN
TERMS OF- WHAT SOME OF TURNED.
A NATIONAL WORK ON A HIGHER
EDUCATION ACCOUNTABILITY
MOVEMENT THERE TO THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING SIMULTANEOUSLY.
ONE IS THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING
A NATIONAL DEGREE SHORTAGE AND
IN TERMS OF THE CHANGES IN THE
WORK FORCE. AND THE
PRODUCTIVITY OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE A
NATIONALLY WAS A PROBLEM.
PREVIOUSLY I THINK DECADES
BEFORE THE QUESTION WAS ABOUT
WHO GETS TO PARTICIPATE IN
COLLEGE. AND WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR INDIVIDUALS IN TERMS OF WHO
GETS THE GIRL WHO GETS TO
GRADUATE. THAT CONVERSATION
SHIFTED TO HOW MANY DEGREE
HOLDERS DO WE NEED TO PRODUCE
NATIONALLY OR FOR THE STATE TO
MAKE. THE DEVIL BACK TO BECOME
THAT TURN A VERY SURE I AND TO
ASK HOW PRODUCTIVE WHERE THEY
WITH PUBLIC DOLLARS IN SOME
CASES FEDERAL DOLLARS. IN THE
STUDENT- FINANCIAL A PROGRAM SO
THAT THAT WAS ONE VARIABLE IS
THE SORT OF NATIONAL
RECOGNITION THAT WE NEED TO BE
MORE PRODUCTIVE AND PRODUCE
SOME DEGREE HOLDERS. ON THE
SECOND WAS THE ABOLITION A
COMMON GOAL AND THE REALIZATION
THAT SOME CAMPUSES WERE
WOEFULLY UNDER PERFORMING AND I
THINK THERE WAS A LOT OF
SURPRISE SHOCK AND ALL WHEN WE
STARTED ABOUT WHAT FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES WORK WITH THE-SECURE. SHARON WHAT THESE WERE
BASED ON WHERE YOU GREW UP OR
WHAT HIGH SCHOOL YOU ATTENDED.
AND I THINK JUST BY SHEER AND
SAW THAT FORCED THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT OUGHT
TO BE WHAT'S A REASONABLE GOAL
FOR OUR INSTITUTIONS IN TERMS
OF GRADUATING A GREATER PERSON
JUST IT RAW. AND ENOUGH AN OLD
THING THING. A BLOOD DATA TO
FRANCE. NO ARE CAN'T IS ONE OF
TO BE AT THE BOTTOM OF THE LIST.
YOU WERE PRODUCED A ARMS OF
NICE TO XIN PERFECT INSIDE. OUR
ABILITY TO JIM CAREFULLY WITH
SOME DEGREE OF SENT TO STAR TO
SHOW. AND A MORE TRANCE WAY HOW
CAN WERE PERFORMING IN VARIOUS
ASPECTS REALLY GOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S ATTENTION. I MEAN IT
WHAT WAS I MEAN SURELY THE DATA
EXISTED BEFORE. THERE WILL BY I
MAY TRY TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
INSTITUTIONAL CULTURAL SHIPS I
SUPPOSE WHEN I'M ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS- THE SHOCK AND I
DIDN'T EXIST BACK IN. TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN YOUR PEOPLE SO
STRESSED OUT ABOUT THE
RECESSION WAS THAT THAT WAS
GOING ON THE THAT. THERE'S LESS
OF A DEGREE SHORTAGE PROBLEM
BECAUSE IT RELIES JOBS AND THE
MONEY WAS BEING CUT SO THAT WAS
TAKING ALL THE ENERGY OF THE
ROOM. I HAVE WHAT THEY THERE'S
ONE OTHER. ELEMENT AND I THINK
IT SPEAKS TO THE CULTURE SHIFT
I THINK. AND MAYBE A GENERATION
AGO THAT IF A STUDENT. ARRIVED
ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS AND FOR
WHATEVER REASON A YEAR LATER
WAS BACK AT HOME WORKING AND AT
THE MALL- THE PERCEPTION WAS
SOMETHING WAS WRONG WITH THE
YOU DIDN'T TRY HARD ENOUGH YOU
WEREN'T MOTIVATED- AND I THINK.
YOU KNOW INSTITUTIONS OF REALLY
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE A SIGN
TRADITIONALLY THE BLAME FOR
ATTRITION OR DROP OUT TO THE
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT THAT'S RIGHT
TODAY WE ARE ASKING WHAT
HAPPENS IN THIS ENVIRONMENT
WHEN A YOUNG STUDENT ARRIVES OR
YOUNG PERSON ARRIVES. THAT MAY
CONTRIBUTE TO WHETHER OR NOT
THERE STUDENT PERSIST TO WORDS
A DEGREE OR THAT BACK HOME
WORKING AT THE MALL A YEAR
LATER AND THAT HAS BEEN A BIG
PART OF THE CULTURAL SHIFT. IS
THAT THE ASSIGNMENT AND THE
ATTRIBUTION OF WHAT HAPPENS TO
STUDENTS HAS COMPLETELY CHANGED
IN HIGHER EDUCATION AND
COMPLETELY CHANGED IN THE C.
ISSUE. AND THE MEDIA ENHANCE
THAT BECAUSE I THINK DOCTOR
MINERS REALLY HIT ON THE HEAD.
EVERY TIME- THIS CONVERSATION
CAME UP AND IN 200-011-2000
TWELVE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
THE ANSWER WAS WE HAVE
DIFFERENT STUDENTS HERE AT THE
CSU THAN IT YOU SEE. AND OUR
STUDENTS CAN'T TAKE A LOAD THEY
HAVE OTHER OBLIGATIONS AND THAT
WAS THE NARRATIVE THAT'S WHY
THE FOCUS IS ALWAYS ON THE SIX
YEAR GRADUATION RATE WHICH AT
THE TIME WAS UNDER FIFTY. BUT
THAT'S WHAT THEY TAKE POINT TO
AND SAY SEE WERE STILL DOING
PRETTY WELL. YOU WILL WAS IT
WAS THE STUDENTS NOT THE AND-
WAS IN THE BARRIERS. AND THE
SECOND PART OF THAT IS THAT.
IT'S FROM A THIRTY THOUSAND
FOOT LEVEL- FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA THE
FOCUS FOR DECADES BECAUSE I GO
BACK TO THE SEVENTIES AND BEING
INVOLVED IN THE CSU. THE FOCUS.
DECADES WAS. LAST ACCESS AND
QUALITY. THOSE ARE THE
STANDARDS THAT WERE EVALUATED
BY THE STUDENTS BY THE FACULTY
BY THE LEADERSHIP. HOW MUCH TO
TUITION WAS OR NOT HOW
ACCESSIBLE- STUDENTS SCHOOL
ADMISSIONS COULD BE AND THAT
WAS WE KEEP IN THE QUALITY AT A
HIGH LEVEL. AND THOSE WERE THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT- THE
METRICS FOR SUCCESS IT WASN'T
ABOUT STUDENT COMPLETION AND
THAT'S THE NEW THING. AND THERE
WAS A VIEW THAT THAT STUDENT
POLLUTION REALLY WAS AN
INSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION. AND
THAT'S WHERE WE TALK ABOUT
CULTURE. THAT'S HOW THINGS IN
MY VIEW EDGE AT SHIFT CHANGE
THIS DOCTOR MINOR HAS INDICATED.
YEAH YEAH THE I MEAN FOR ME I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS SO VERY
MUCH GREAT PROGRESS I MEAN WHAT
ONE QUESTION I SUPPOSE I HAVE
IS- WHAT PERCENTAGE OF YOUR
STUDENTS. SHOW UP ON CAN'T
EXPECTING TO GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS WHEN YOU KNOW. THE DAY
THEY FIRST AND ROLL THIS
ROUGHLY 84% SYSTEM ONE YEAH. SO
THEY'RE STILL IT YOU KNOW WE
CELEBRATE ENORMOUS SUCCESS AND
WE YOU KNOW WE WERE ABLE TO
GET. SACRAMENTO FROM NINE TO
TWENTY BUT- THE GAP BETWEEN
EIGHT THIRTY HIM TWENTY SONORA
MISS AND- SO THEY'RE STILL. AND
MAYBE THAT'S A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION I DON'T KNOW I MEAN
I YOU KNOW BUT- NO I MEAN WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORKS THE YET TO
DO- ON THAT FIRST LIST OUT WE
WERE NEAR THE BOTTOM- WE WERE
NOT PROUD TO BE. ON THERE- AND
SO THERE WAS SOME TALK IN AWE.
OF HOW WHAT ARE WE DOING- SELF
REFLECTION. IN HOW WE'RE DOING
THINGS- AND WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES OF MORE
AMERICAN WILL CONTAIN A MAY.
AND I THINK YOU YOUR QUESTION
UNDERSCORES WHAT IS MY BELIEF
WHICH IS THAT. THE GOALS THAT
THIS TEMAS STAT THE FORTY BY
TWO TWENTY. OUR AND READ. I
KNOW WE CAN A LOT MORE WITH
THAT. THE FOR YOU GRAY.
AVERAGES BETWEEN SEPT 80%
CAMPUS TODAY. WHEN I SPOKE WITH
PRESIDENT THAT APOLLO ON A
RECENT THIS WAS WILL GO UP
ABOUT THIS SHE SAYS WE'RE TO
GET TO KNOW. SHE NOT SET THEY
AND THEY ARE PER TO GET EVEN
HIGHER AND I KNOW THAT ARE
STUDENTS CSU CAN DO AS WELL.
AND SO WHILE WE ARE MAKING
ENORMOUS PROGRESS IN MANY CASES
I KNOW THAT WE CAN DO A LOT
BETTER NOT ONLY BECAUSE WE NEED
IT FOR CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY BUT WE COULD WE KNOW
THE TRAGEDY OF THE STUDENT IS
DONE EVERYTHING RIGHT GOTTEN
THE GRADES GOT ADMITTED TAKING
THE LOANS AND THEN HAVE TO DROP
OUT WITH NO DEGREE AND- THAT
THAT'S A TRAP. THAT I HAD YOU
KNOW WE DON'T LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT'S
UNCOMFORTABLE THAT'S PARTLY WHY
IT'S NOT DISCUSS FOR IT THEN IN
THE PAST BUT NOW IT'S BEEN
AIRED OUT AND- AND WE'RE SEEING
THE RESULTS. CAN SO I WHEN
OPENING UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
IF SOMEONE IS HERE I WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS BEFORE
WE CONCLUDE THE HEARING PLEASE
COME ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE IN%
AND OUT LET US KNOW ANYBODY
HERE WANT TO HAVE ANYTHING TO
SAY. OKAY I KNOW THAT THAT THIS
SIZE THIS YEAR CHANCELLOR
WHITE. IS COMPLETING HIS-
INCREDIBLE SERVICE TO THE CSU.
AND THERE'S A LOT TO PRAISE HIM
FOR- AND THE AMAZING THINGS
THAT THE CSU HAS DONE DURING
THE TIME THAT HE HAS SERVED. AS
OUR LEADER THERE- BUT I BELIEVE
THAT THE PROGRESS THAT YOU'VE
ELIMINATED TODAY DOCTOR MINOR
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY CAMPUSES
THAT THAT ARE HERE TODAY-
REALLY ARE A PART OF HIS LEGACY
THAT HE HAS PUT THE CSU AND THE
CAMPUS IS ON AND AN INCREDIBLY-
ASCENDING TRAJECTORY OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT AND SUCCESS EVEN
GREATER THAN HE HE AND I AND-
MANY COULD HAVE EVER IMAGINED
SO  WANT TO. SHARE MY PRAISE
TO HIM AND FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN THIS AREA OBVIOUSLY SO MANY
OTHER PLACES IN WHICH SHE HAS
DONE GREAT THINGS FOR THE CSU
AND OUR STATE. THE THAT I WANT
HE WILL OFFER AN AND TO FIND
SHARING YOUR STORIES. PLEASE
THANK YOU PRESIDENT'S FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND OUR PRAISE FOR
THEIR GREAT. THE GREAT WORK
THAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REPRESENT TODAY. THE DOCTOR
MINOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUING WORKING LEADERSHIP
IN THIS AREA WE HAVE HAD LOTS
OF CONVERSATIONS. I KNOW WE
HAVE A LOT MORE TO AT TO BE
HAD. BECAUSE WE'RE ALL EXCITED
ABOUT THE GREAT WORK THAT YOU
ARE DOING- AND WE KNOW IT CAN
BE EVEN A EVEN GREATER AND WE
WANT TO BE PARTNERS IN THAT. SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU ALL FOR
ATTENDING AND FOR LISTENING
AND- THIS SENATE COMMITTEE ON
STUDENT SUCCESS IS ADJOURNED.